All right. 2023 Holiday Special Live. Take it away, Jason. All right. Maybe before we jump straight into business, Patrick, how are you doing now that you got your audio issues sorted out? I'm doing okay. Yeah? you reflected on on this year when it comes to programming work uh you know uh stuff you've been studying what's your overall feel of 2023 i mean i feel like 2023 was the year everyone decided ai was going to happen but i'm a little depressed i'm a little depressed to find out the new gemini demo videos were all fake. So that makes me sad in my heart.
好的。2023年假日特别直播。开始吧，Jason。好的。在进入正题之前，Patrick，你解决了音频问题后感觉怎么样？我还行。是吗？你回顾一下这一年的编程工作，还有你一直在研究的东西，你对2023年的整体感觉如何？我觉得2023年是每个人都认定人工智能将要爆发的一年，但我发现新的Gemini演示视频全是假的，这让我有点沮丧。这让我的内心感到难过。
Yeah, well, they got in trouble last time because they were not fake when they released Bard. And it was really embarrassing. So this time they totally faked it. You really can't win if you're Google. But yeah, I think it's been a good year. It's been a good year. I feel like we're stabilizing after the whole, you know, 2020, uh, stuff. Just say that we'll leave it there. Um, so, so yeah, so I think, I think it's good, but I'm curious what's going to happen
是啊，他们上次发布Bard时因为视频不是假的而惹上了麻烦。那真的很尴尬。所以这次他们完全造假了。如果你是谷歌，你真的怎么做都不对。但我觉得这是不错的一年。这是不错的一年。我觉得在经历了2020年那些事之后，我们正在趋于稳定。我们就说到这儿吧。所以，是的，我觉得挺好的，但我很好奇接下来会发生什么。
with the job market. You know, it's, it's, everyone's a little nervous. So, uh, hopefully things are up, uh, crypto's ripping again. So I'm starting to hear people get excited, which is excited to see people excited about something. So AI and crypto being exciting again could be cool. Yeah, I mean, this time I actually have crypto
关于就业市场。你知道，每个人都有点紧张。所以，希望情况能好转，加密货币又开始暴涨了。所以我开始听到人们感到兴奋，看到人们对某事感到兴奋是件好事。所以人工智能和加密货币再次变得令人兴奋可能很酷。是的，我的意思是，这次我实际上第一次拥有了加密货币。
for the first time. So, you know, we've missed every other crypto wave. Maybe we'll actually catch this one if it goes to the moon. I saw that there are upcoming two SpaceX launches scheduled for this evening as we're recording this podcast which is december 11th uh so i think that's pretty cool from like uh two launch pads very near to each other in cape canaveral so um yeah i space space is becoming
所以，你知道，我们错过了之前的每一次加密货币浪潮。如果这次它能一飞冲天，也许我们真的能赶上。我看到在我们录制这期播客（12月11日）的今天晚上，SpaceX有两次发射计划，我觉得这很酷，两个发射台离卡纳维拉尔角的距离非常近，所以，是的，太空正在再次变得重要，这很酷，非常酷。
big again that's cool very cool so now where you live do you see the spacex launches like in the sky go look outside yes okay all right very cool and it's not too cloudy i'm far enough away where yeah it's often obscured by clouds okay got it um the thing about the job market's really interesting um i really don't know what's going to happen there. I mean, one thing that I guess really scared me about this year was just a huge RTO push. And did you feel at any point? So just like a bit of context. So Patrick and I both moved out of the Bay Area, you know since sometime around you know sometime during the
那么，在你住的地方，你能看到SpaceX的发射吗？比如去外面看？是的，好的，好的，非常酷，而且云层不是太厚。我离得足够远，所以它经常被云层遮挡。好的，明白了。关于就业市场的事情真的很有趣，我真的不知道那里会发生什么。我的意思是，今年让我感到害怕的一件事就是大规模的重返办公室（RTO）推动。你有没有在某个时刻感觉到？为了提供一点背景，Patrick和我都在湾区搬走了，你知道，大概是在……
the the you know catastrophe and um you know yeah so so hearing stories on linkedin of folks saying oh you know i have to pack up and and move move to seattle or something like that that was definitely a scary one of the scariest things of the year but it seems like it's kind of stabilized at this point you know there's there's there's two different camps neither one seems to really be budging so yeah i i i don't know i i listened to actually some economists talk about it which was different than hearing software engineers talk about it because software engineers are obviously colored by uh personal vested interest let's say uh because it's highly personal so there's some economists talk to about it and they were sort of saying that if you look at the rate
那场灾难期间。所以，在领英上听到人们说“哦，我不得不收拾行李搬到西雅图之类的地方”，这绝对是今年最可怕的事情之一。但目前看来它已经稳定下来了，有两个不同的阵营，似乎谁也不肯让步。所以我不知道，我实际上听了一些经济学家谈论这个问题，这与听软件工程师谈论它不同，因为软件工程师显然带有个人既得利益的色彩，因为这非常个人化。所以有一些经济学家谈论它，他们说如果你看看这个比率……
that it was before and the rate it's going to be now and like where it's settling out and sort of like barring some sort of drastic change that it is just going to be a much, much larger portion of people spend more time working from home, whether that's fully from home or part of the week at home. They're like the sort of cats out of the bag. Everyone already figured out that it is okay and it does work. So there will probably be, it's a gradient
它以前是什么样，现在会是什么样，以及它最终会稳定在什么水平，除非发生某种剧烈的变化，否则会有更多的人花更多的时间在家工作，无论是完全在家还是每周在家工作几天。他们就像是“纸包不住火了”。每个人都已经意识到这是可以的，而且是行得通的。所以这可能是一个渐进的过程……
or probably a hybrid work for the foreseeable future. But they were kind of indicating that they believe it's here to stay uh if nothing else it's a competitive advantage for companies that don't do a fully in office thing to recruit sort of like key talent and so um that hearing someone outside the field say that and they were also talking about sort of implications for like just how much gas is consumed um by people right or not and office space and it we forget you know it's the classic traffic waves thing if you've ever seen that it actually doesn't take sort of a lot of change to sometimes swing wildly supply chains or bandwidth or you know insert your favorite uh example here and so uh sometimes actually only
或者在可预见的未来可能是混合办公。但他们暗示他们认为这种模式会持续下去，如果说有什么不同的话，那就是对于那些不实行完全办公室办公的公司来说，这是一种招聘关键人才的竞争优势。所以，听到圈外人这么说，他们还谈到了对汽油消耗量、办公空间的影响。我们忘了，你知道，如果你见过经典的交通波理论，其实不需要太大的变化有时就会剧烈地影响供应链或带宽，或者插入你喜欢的任何例子。所以，有时实际上只有……
a 10 decrease in the demand for like commercial real estate as an example leads to mass vacancies just because uh you'll find new and creative ways or do something different or go with the barely manageable office and so i think we've not fully seen the impacts of those thing yet because those leases are often long and so we'll see yeah you know you know i'm usually i'm usually a little bit bearish on vr i mean i have an oculus i actually used it yesterday i use it you know several times a week for exercise do boxing and other things on the oculus and so i'm using it regularly but um you know i never really saw the sort of commercial appeal or it hasn't been that, in my opinion, there hasn't really been that killer app. But I wonder if this is really that opportunity that's going to reveal itself, right?
商业地产需求下降10%就会导致大规模空置，仅仅是因为你会找到新的创造性方法，或者做些不同的事情，或者使用勉强够用的办公室。所以我认为我们还没有完全看到这些事情的影响，因为租约通常很长，所以我们拭目以待。是的，你知道，我通常对VR有点看跌。我的意思是，我有一个Oculus，我昨天还用了它，我每周用它几次来锻炼，在Oculus上做拳击和其他事情，所以我经常使用它。但是，你知道，我从来没有真正看到那种商业吸引力，或者在我看来，还没有那种杀手级应用。但我不知道这是否真的是那个即将显现的机会，对吧？
Because what you'll hear folks say is you miss out on the water cooler chat or you can't go on the whiteboard and whiteboard with other people. But you're not doing that all day. I mean, there were definitely days when I was going into the office where even when everyone was in an office, they weren't in my office. There was a whole urban sprawl of buildings in our campus, and then there was still seattle and other places and so there were definitely days where i basically was in a conference room almost the entire day um just just uh um talking to people from all over and so um and so those days you know people wouldn't even know if you were at home or not and then the actual days where you want to get around a whiteboard,
因为你会听到人们说，你会错过饮水机旁的闲聊，或者你不能去白板前和别人一起写写画画。但你不会整天都在做那个。我的意思是，我确实有去办公室的日子，即使每个人都在办公室，他们也不在我的办公室。我们的园区里有一大片城市扩张式的建筑，然后还有西雅图和其他地方，所以确实有几天我基本上整天都在会议室里，和来自各地的人交谈。所以，那些日子人们甚至不知道你是否在家。而真正你想围在白板前的日子……
if you were to schedule those, they don't really need to be very spontaneous, even though they were. But you could schedule those, and then everyone could put on their VR headset and sit around a VR whiteboard and brainstorm. They could do that once a week. Yeah, actually, VR is a good one i think we haven't we're talking about
如果你安排这些时间，它们其实不需要非常自发，尽管它们确实是自发的。但你可以安排这些时间，然后每个人都可以戴上VR头显，坐在VR白板周围进行头脑风暴。他们每周可以做一次。是的，其实VR是一个很好的例子，我想我们还没谈到……
predictions i think i think 2023 vr wasn't a thing for me yet but i have hopes for 2024 there are some key things the new oculus coming late in the year uh and okay well i guess i'll save it uh for 2024 predictions but uh but yeah that that's a great point what the i guess the thing i hear about remote work is that i i think resonates is depending on the kind of personality you have depending on where you are in your career and depending on like the nature of your tasking makes a very large impact and the thing is those things are not constant over your career and they're not constant even throughout the year and so uh i think that people say this you know oh it's very difficult to innovate you know in far-flung places but i i i don't know i think it requires like you said careful planning and i'm not clear that
预测。我想2023年VR对我来说还不是什么大事，但我对2024年抱有希望。有一些关键的事情，新的Oculus在年底推出，好吧，我想我会把它留到2024年的预测中。但这是一个很好的观点。关于远程办公，我认为引起共鸣的是，这取决于你的性格类型，取决于你职业生涯所处的阶段，以及取决于你的任务性质，这会产生很大的影响。而且这些东西在你的职业生涯中并不是恒定的，甚至在一年中也不是恒定的。所以，我认为人们说“在偏远的地方很难创新”，但我不知道，我认为这需要像你说的仔细规划，我不确定……
everyone thrived under spontaneous you know interruption and let's sit down and talk about this and we have this come up on my team recently we were trying to let's call spontaneous, you know, interruption and let's sit down and talk about this. And we have this come up on my team recently, we were trying to, let's call it innovate, you know, not just turn the crank on some stuff, we were trying to like, yeah, figure out some new stuff. And we made a point to say, like, we're going to do this on Thursday, I think it was on Monday. And then, you know, Tuesday and Wednesday, when we briefly met together, we sort of added things for people to kind of think about and sort of like not go prepare slides for, but just when we came together on Thursday or whatever, be ready to sort of think these are the sets of things. And it was actually interesting because rather than making it halfway through the brainstorming session and someone going, oh, what about this? We kind of had a notional like set of things we needed to make sure we handled and discussed.
每个人都在自发的干扰下茁壮成长，比如“让我们坐下来谈谈这个”。我的团队最近也遇到了这种情况，我们试图进行所谓的创新，不仅仅是机械地完成工作，我们试图弄清楚一些新东西。我们特意说，我们要周四做这件事，我想是在周一。然后，周二和周三，当我们简短会面时，我们为人们增加了一些需要思考的事情，不是去准备幻灯片，而是当我们周四聚在一起时，准备好思考这些事情。这其实很有趣，因为与其在头脑风暴会议进行到一半时有人问“那这个呢？”，我们有了一个概念性的集合，确保我们处理并讨论了这些事情。
Now, it wasn't necessarily completely effective, but at least, you know, I found i found it yes it took a little bit more thought but it was okay yep yep that makes sense yeah during during the pandemic we also had some different brainstorming sessions and uh um we used um some software i forgot what it was called um but uh it was really quite good it it uh man i wish i could remember what it's called but it had um mapping yeah that's right yeah it had this uh it had a bunch of these different kind of icebreaker and different different corporate kind of tools different mind mapping tools all in one and um you kind of share with other people it's like a google docs kind of environment we're all working on interactively and so yeah i think there'll be there'll be just more of that as as companies realize that there's really no
现在，它不一定完全有效，但至少我发现它确实需要多一点思考，但没问题。是的，这很有道理。在疫情期间，我们也进行了一些不同的头脑风暴会议，我们使用了一些软件，我忘了它叫什么了，但它真的很好。天哪，我真希望我能记得它叫什么，但它有思维导图，没错，它有很多这种不同类型的破冰工具和不同的企业工具，所有的思维导图工具都在一个软件里。你可以和别人分享，就像谷歌文档那样的环境，我们都在交互式地工作。所以，是的，我认为随着公司意识到真的没有回头路了，会有更多这样的工具，正如你所说。
no going back as you said um did you get on the uh portable gaming pc rage this year i feel like i feel like that was another thing this year. Did you get any? I was so tempted, but I didn't. Yeah, I am going to get a Steam Deck, I think. But I'm going to wait a little bit. Yeah, I just can't pull the trigger yet. But it's been looking really nice.
你今年有没有赶上便携式游戏PC的热潮？我觉得这是今年的另一件事。你买了吗？我太想买了，但我没买。是的，我想我会买一个Steam Deck。但我会再等一会儿。是的，我还没法下定决心。但它看起来真的很不错。
I will say for the couple long-haul flights I took this year, if you're willing to pack the Steam Deck, oh, it's so nice. It's just like, because I don't get a ton of time to just sit. And then I had, you know, three, four, five, six hours to just sit and like play video games, you know, as long as you didn't kill your battery or you had a charging strategy. But that was just such a game changer for me. Yes, first world problems that you have to sit for six hours with nothing to do but uh it was really awesome yeah that's great um
我得说，对于我今年乘坐的几次长途飞行，如果你愿意带上Steam Deck，哦，那真是太棒了。因为我没有太多时间可以坐着。然后我有三、四、五、六个小时可以坐着玩电子游戏，只要你不把电池耗尽或者你有充电策略。但这对我来说简直是改变游戏规则。是的，这是你必须坐六个小时无事可做的“第一世界问题”，但它真的很棒。是的，那太好了。
yeah i think the the uh steam deck looks super nice i definitely want to get my hands on one but there's a there's other alternatives to now coming out depending on like what set of yeah i saw that the the rog ally or something like that yeah and there's there's some sort of like other second tier companies making them too there's a there's a bunch but yeah the steam deck obviously i think has like uh most people have well i shouldn't say many people have a steam library that's just like a huge backlog and there's like integration with that i don't know it's like the ease of it right just sitting down and playing it and the user base is there and for games that have a bad key mapping you know there's always like a user submitted key
是的，我觉得Steam Deck看起来超级棒，我绝对想弄到一个，但现在还有其他选择，取决于……是的，我看到了ROG Ally之类的东西。还有一些二线公司也在做，有很多。但Steam Deck显然，我认为大多数人都有一个Steam库，里面有巨大的积压游戏，而且有集成。我不知道，这就像它的易用性，坐下来玩，用户群就在那里。对于按键映射不好的游戏，总有用户提交的按键……
mapping ranked by popularity and you can just switch over to someone else's and yeah that's very nice yeah actually speaking of games the uh did you see this fortnite thing where you you now have lego fortnite there's all these other games inside of fortnite that that came out i will i played for once i'm on the ball this time i saw it i was like really cool so i have kids that are you know i guess you know uh upper elementary early middle school i told them and they're like no that's dumb we just want to play real fortnite and i was like no no no let's play like this is gonna be great so we started up and my daughter and i did play a bunch of the lego fortnite i will say for being just a blatant ripoff of minecraft but like in fortnite world i really enjoy it was like a nice fresh take on you know not exactly the voxel
按受欢迎程度排序的映射，你可以直接切换到别人的。是的，那非常好。说到游戏，你看到Fortnite（堡垒之夜）那个事了吗？你现在有了乐高Fortnite，Fortnite里面还有所有这些其他游戏。我玩了一次，这次我跟上了潮流。我看到了，我觉得真的很酷。我有孩子，大概是小学高年级或初中低年级，我告诉他们，他们说“不，那太蠢了，我们只想玩真正的Fortnite”。我说“不不不，让我们玩玩看，这会很棒”。所以我们开始了，我和我女儿确实玩了很多乐高Fortnite。我得说，作为一个对Minecraft（我的世界）的公然抄袭，但在Fortnite世界里，我真的很喜欢。这是一种新鲜的尝试，不是完全的体素……
not exactly minecraft but in my opinion maybe i'm biased that's clearly where they're trying to go minecraft is such a juggernaut and i think that you know they want to piece that action but i i really enjoyed it the game was it had that cycle where you just always like ready to go play do the next thing like get one more little step up they had it very well polished yeah so you know i had the opposite situation with respect to kids where my older son was the one who told me about it and he's like dad we should try this kids at school are playing it and so um and so we tried it yeah i agree i think it was pretty good i like how um you know i guess for me the days of being creative are just kind of over on video games you know i just i just don't have it in me to like spend a bunch of time to like meticulously create my base and everything and and so um you
不完全是Minecraft，但在我看来，也许我有偏见，这显然是他们试图去的地方。Minecraft是一个庞然大物，我认为他们想分一杯羹。但我真的很喜欢它，游戏有那种循环，你总是准备好去玩，做下一件事，再进一步。他们做得非常精致。是的，关于孩子，我的情况正好相反，我大儿子告诉我的，他说“爸爸，我们应该试试这个，学校里的孩子都在玩”。所以我们试了，是的，我同意，我觉得它相当不错。我喜欢……你知道，对我来说，在电子游戏中发挥创造力的日子已经结束了，我没有精力花大量时间去精心打造我的基地。所以……
know i like how they had the prefabs where you could just say i want a house and then it would just show you all the different pieces and you just had to collect all the resources so you know my son built his own kind of custom house uh my four-year-old threw tantrums until we put him in his own world where there were no enemies he wanted to play too he's like oh i want to play you know everyone else is playing and so we're like yeah come on into so i made him an account and everything he joined our server and then he was like you know bitten to death by a spider or something and and and through a tantrum uh yeah i mean another game that i got on just recently that i've been
我喜欢他们有预制件，你可以说“我想要一栋房子”，然后它会向你展示所有不同的部件，你只需要收集所有资源。所以我儿子建造了他自己的定制房子。我四岁的孩子大发脾气，直到我们把他放进他自己的世界，那里没有敌人。他也想玩，他说“哦，我想玩，其他人都在玩”。所以我们说“好吧，进来吧”。我给他开了一个账户，他加入了我们的服务器，然后他被一只蜘蛛咬死了，或者类似的事情，然后大发脾气。是的，另一个我最近刚开始玩的游戏……
enjoying the like pickup put down is dave the diver have you heard about dave the diver oh man i've heard about that i heard it was really good okay it's such a goofy like mechanic but it's just sort of like a job simulator kind of game but you have like one you rotate through various you know sort of like parts of your day in the life of a slightly overweight diver by day and uh working at a sushi bar by night and so during the day you need to dive into the ocean and capture fish and then at night you you know work with your sushi chef to make the proper dishes from the food that you caught and you know serve patrons that come in and so it's basically a series of mini games right so diving is its own
我很享受那种拿起来就能玩、放下就能走的感觉，是《潜水员戴夫》（Dave the Diver）。你听说过《潜水员戴夫》吗？天哪，我听说过，听说它真的很好。好的，它的机制很滑稽，就像一个工作模拟器游戏，但你扮演一个稍微超重的潜水员，白天潜水，晚上在寿司店工作。所以白天你需要潜入海洋捕捉鱼类，晚上你和你的寿司厨师一起用你捕获的食物制作合适的菜肴，并为进来的顾客服务。所以它基本上是一系列小游戏，对吧？所以潜水有它自己的……
mini game with a set of trade-offs and then the sushi at night there's you need to bus you know the sushi stuff makes the dish you got to take it to the person who wants the dish and then you got to like clean the table grind up the wasabi serve tea you know there's like various you know little things you need to do so yeah but it has that that really nice like repetition rate where you don't need to sit down and play for you know eight hours or two hours or one hour you know you can play for 10 minutes 15 minutes and do one dive or do one you know night at the sushi bar and it's not super pressing you that like you're gonna be hungry if you don't go get apples or you're gonna like if you so far as far as i can tell there's
带有一系列权衡的小游戏，然后晚上的寿司，你需要收拾桌子，寿司师傅制作菜肴，你必须把它送到想要菜肴的人那里，然后你必须清理桌子、磨芥末、倒茶。所以，是的，但它有那种非常好的重复率，你不需要坐下来玩八小时、两小时或一小时。你可以玩10分钟、15分钟，做一次潜水或一个晚上的寿司店工作。它不会给你很大的压力，比如如果你不去摘苹果就会饿死，或者如果你……据我所知，它有……
very low repercussions for screwing up which allows you to sort of like experiment and try and you know do different things so i've really been enjoying dave the diver on my steam deck actually yeah actually related to that i got a game called uh cuba factorium which is like a yeah it's a weird name but it's basically like a watered down or simplified factorio okay um but there's a couple of mechanics they did really well number one uh similar to what you said there's no pressure like the people uh it's not it's more like um a rim world or a dwarf fortress actually than a factorio so you have a you know a group of people and you kind of give them tasks by like you know drawing blueprints of buildings and all of that um but there's there's no time pressure so there's
犯错的后果非常小，这让你能够尝试和做不同的事情。所以我真的很享受在我的Steam Deck上玩《潜水员戴夫》。是的，其实说到这个，我有一个游戏叫《Kubifaktorium》，名字很奇怪，但它基本上是一个简化版的Factorio（异星工厂）。好的，但他们有几个机制做得很好。第一，和你说的类似，没有压力。它更像是一个RimWorld（环世界）或Dwarf Fortress（矮人要塞），而不是Factorio。所以你有一群人，你通过绘制建筑蓝图来给他们分配任务，但没有时间压力。所以……
the people don't starve or anything like that you could just let it idle and um um it's like playing factorio with no monsters you know if you idle you know you'll slowly accumulate some resources but you know with you working on the efficiencies it's that's the way to push the game forward um the other thing they did really well is you know with factorio or any of these games the first time you play it you don't really know what you're doing. And so you make a bunch of bad design decisions and then you feel really compelled to start over. Right. What this game does is is you basically hop from island to island.
人们不会饿死之类的，你可以让它闲置。它就像玩没有怪物的Factorio。如果你闲置，你会慢慢积累一些资源，但你通过提高效率来推动游戏前进。他们做得很好的另一件事是，在Factorio或任何这些游戏中，你第一次玩时真的不知道自己在做什么。所以你做了一堆糟糕的设计决定，然后你感到非常有必要重新开始。没错。这个游戏所做的是，你基本上是从一个岛屿跳到另一个岛屿。
And so they did a really good job at the pacing. Like when I unlocked, you know, when I unlocked conveyor belts and like I'd up until then been doing the whole thing, which is people carrying goods back and forth. Of course, like it massively changes the way you want to design the base. And so that's just the time where they're like, OK, you know, you unlock conveyor belts, you won this level, go to the next level and and start from scratch. But you have all the research from the first level and and start from scratch but you have all the research from the first level and a bunch of resources and all that oh that's awesome i saw for dice and sphere program which i feel had a pretty good cut at that mechanic as well uh adding sort of enemies
所以他们在节奏控制上做得很好。比如当我解锁了传送带，在那之前我一直做的是人们搬运货物。当然，这极大地改变了你想要设计基地的方式。所以这就是他们说“好的，你解锁了传送带，你赢得了这一关，去下一关从零开始”的时候。但你拥有第一关的所有研究成果，还有一堆资源。哦，那太棒了。我看到了《戴森球计划》（Dyson Sphere Program），我觉得它在那个机制上也做得很好，增加了敌人……
and you know you have to kind of start your world over but i also learned that apparently which i don't know, I guess it goes into the economics of game design, but they have a thing where when you're building up your world, they do a sort of weighted average, but recording of your peak science output in a given save. So if you're making,
你知道，你必须重新开始你的世界。但我还了解到，这似乎进入了游戏设计的经济学，他们有一个机制，当你建立你的世界时，他们会记录你在某个存档中的峰值科学产出。所以如果你正在制造……
I don't even remember the color, blue cubes at a certain rate, not the total you produce. You can't just let the game sit there and run, but like how many cubes per second you reached at your peak gives you these like metadata points and then you can use those points in the future as like expenditure almost like a roguelike to sort of skip ahead in your research in your new site or they're going to add i guess permadeath or death and so you can spend these metadata credits to like restore it so it's this really interesting dynamic where you
我不记得颜色了，以某种速率制造蓝色立方体，而不是总产量。你不能只是让游戏在那儿运行，但你达到的每秒立方体峰值会给你这些元数据点，然后你可以在未来使用这些点作为支出，几乎像Roguelike游戏一样，在你的新存档中跳过研究，或者他们要增加永久死亡，所以你可以花费这些元数据点来恢复。所以这是一个非常有趣的动态，你……
should continue building up your worlds to like have this really massive focus on certain science production, because then later you'll be able to use those as like a sort of shortcut for future gaming. So I thought that was really interesting. Very cool. Yeah, I'll have to check that out. So, okay, let's jump into questions. But before that that maybe we'll
应该继续建立你的世界，以对某些科学生产有巨大的关注，因为以后你将能够利用这些作为未来游戏的捷径。所以我认为这非常有趣。非常酷。是的，我得去看看。那么，好的，让我们进入问题环节。但在那之前，也许我们会……
we'll we'll do the the typical like a recap and prediction so we did we did talk about 2023 my predictions for 2024 um and we called out one of them which is i do think there'll be some type of vr plus work um you know i just think the audience for that is massive and there's a huge schism right now that that could bridge over um so so yeah i do think that that's something that will come around um you know i feel like the cost of doing all this AI work is going to become a bigger and bigger problem. I think a lot of these ML training, machine learning training jobs are very inefficient because they're very complex. You have to do all this data transformation, and then you have to train the model and and the data
做典型的回顾和预测。我们确实谈到了2023年，我对2024年的预测。我们提到了其中一个，即我确实认为会有某种VR加工作的模式。我认为它的受众是巨大的，现在有一个巨大的分歧可以弥合。所以，是的，我确实认为那是会出现的事情。我觉得做所有这些AI工作的成本将成为一个越来越大的问题。我认为很多这些机器学习训练工作效率非常低，因为它们非常复杂。你必须进行所有这些数据转换，然后你必须训练模型，而数据……
transformation is embarrassingly parallel but the training the model is is not um and so the whole thing is extremely inefficient and uh you know i don't know if it's really it's gotten a little bit better but it hasn't gotten better it hasn't kept up with the price of gpus per hour and all that which is skyrocketing so i would say next year i definitely expect to see more around lowering the cost of doing all this there's also some environmental aspects um i said i think it's like every bitcoin transaction uses a gallon of water or something i don't know there's something wild like that but um i think efficiency is going to be more and more important um and uh i guess maybe at one final prediction
转换是尴尬的并行，但训练模型不是。所以整个事情效率极低。我不知道它是否真的好转了一点，但它没有跟上每小时GPU的价格，所有这些都在飙升。所以我说明年我绝对期望看到更多关于降低这些成本的事情。还有一些环境方面的问题。我说过，我想每笔比特币交易都要消耗一加仑水之类的，我不知道，有类似这样疯狂的事情。但我认为效率会变得越来越重要。我想也许最后一个预测……
um i do think that that uh i think that this risk v is going to is going to really take off um and we're you know we're going to see like a whole bunch of cheaper hardware come from that um can you tell me what that is oh yeah so is it v or five i i've always said V, but I don't know if that's correct. Okay. So it's basically a simpler architecture. And Patrick, you probably know a lot more than I do. But you have x86 and you have ARM, different processors. So for example, if you build some software on your PC, that's probably using x86. And so you can't just run that on your
我认为RISC-V真的会起飞。我们将看到一大堆更便宜的硬件出现。你能告诉我那是什么吗？哦，是V还是5？我一直说V，但我不知道那是否正确。好的。所以它基本上是一个更简单的架构。Patrick，你可能比我了解得多得多。但你有x86，你有ARM，不同的处理器。例如，如果你在PC上构建一些软件，那可能使用x86。所以你不能直接在你的……
phone so like you know different processors need different you know uh compilers and all of that and so this risk uh five or risk v is a completely open source specification so so you know anyone can go and make a processor and uh um and your code that you compiled on one risk v machine or cross compiled to a risk v architecture will run on another one and so you know it kind of blows up the duopoly on architectures do i get that right you probably know way more than i do about this yeah Yeah, no, no, I think you have it right. I guess like to put terms on it. So risk V is a ISA and instruction set architecture. So you're right, the two big ones are arm and x86. But x86 is sort of notoriously like very complicated, and really implemented by Intel and AMD are the only two people really make make x86 chips, x86 being that that
手机上运行它。所以不同的处理器需要不同的编译器等等。所以这个RISC-V是一个完全开源的规范。所以任何人都可以去制造一个处理器，你在一个RISC-V机器上编译的代码，或者交叉编译到RISC-V架构的代码，都可以在另一个上运行。所以它打破了架构上的双头垄断。我理解对了吗？你可能比我了解得多得多。是的，不，不，我想你理解对了。我想用术语来说。RISC-V是一个ISA，指令集架构。所以你是对的，两个大的是ARM和x86。但x86众所周知非常复杂，而且实际上只有英特尔和AMD真正制造x86芯片，x86就是那个……
instruction set architecture, the bytecode that, you know, maps to specific operations. And so then there's ARM, and many people license ARM to have their own implementations, though. So you ARM different than x86 has a lot of, or at least in my opinion, has like a lot of modularity to it so you can add you know extra things like if you're building a digital signal processor a dsp you may add a lot of multiply accumulates which are useful for like ir fir filters um versus you know if you're not you don't include that one so it is more you know modular but you pay licensing fees to arm for you know basically the instructions on like how to do all that like what you know, modular, but you pay licensing fees to ARM for, you know, basically the instructions on like how to do all that, like what, you know, buying existing blocks to drop into an FPGA or
指令集架构，映射到特定操作的字节码。然后是ARM，许多人授权ARM来拥有他们自己的实现。不过，ARM与x86不同，它有很多，或者至少在我看来，有很多模块化，所以你可以添加额外的东西。比如如果你正在构建一个数字信号处理器（DSP），你可能会添加很多乘法累加器，这对FIR滤波器很有用，而如果你不需要，你就不包含那个。所以它更模块化，但你向ARM支付许可费，基本上是为了指令……
to your design for an ASIC. And so risk V is supposed to be more collaborative and unencumbered by the licensing you need to do. And so lots of people hopefully will build these modules out and then sort of manufacturers who are trying to compete very, very, very cheaply won't have to sort of invent their own instruction set, which, like you said, of these uh chip manufacturers are trying to start up and kind of gain momentum uh by being in this ecosystem so for things like a raspberry pi or an arduino or whatever they could use this and not have to pay uh you know licensing fees to which would be part even if you buy a chip off the shelf that already paid like part of the price you pay for it would be the licensing fee to ARM in a lot of cases if it's ARM-based,
购买现有的模块放入FPGA或你的ASIC设计中。所以RISC-V应该是更协作的，并且不受你需要支付的许可费的束缚。所以希望很多人会构建这些模块，然后那些试图以非常非常低廉的价格竞争的制造商就不必发明他们自己的指令集。正如你所说，这些芯片制造商正试图通过在这个生态系统中立足来启动并获得动力。所以对于像树莓派或Arduino之类的东西，他们可以使用这个，而不必支付许可费。即使你购买现成的芯片，你支付的价格中有一部分在很多情况下也是给ARM的许可费，如果是基于ARM的话……
which is very common for embedded chips. And so, yeah. So interesting prediction that'll take off. It's been a slow burn growth and we have started to see some more production outputs from folks for those chips. So that's a good prediction. Yeah, what are your predictions so i was going to press you on yours first hang on oh sure i was going to make you get a little bit more a little bit more bold here so you said vr for work
这在嵌入式芯片中非常常见。所以，是的。所以这是一个有趣的预测，它会起飞。它一直是一个缓慢的增长，我们已经开始看到人们生产出更多这些芯片。所以这是一个很好的预测。是的，你的预测是什么？我本来想先逼问你的。等等，哦，当然，我本来想让你在这里更大胆一点。所以你说VR用于工作……
that was one of your predictions so i was going to push you on say uh what do you think that's going to look like that was that was a little hand wavy so so okay i'm like gotta hold you to it next year i think that the right play here is is you know the idea of you wearing a vr headset all day i just don't see that happening um monitors not like having nine monitors spread out like a you know stock trader yeah yeah and you know even like if you forget about the weight and all the encumbrance of wearing the headset and everything um you know people kind of like i think people are underestimating just like the proprioception part of it like just the fact that like you know you look in the real world and you touch things like you put your hand on your desk and your desk is
那是你的预测之一。所以我本来想逼问你，你认为那会是什么样子？那有点含糊。所以，好吧，我得在明年监督你。我认为这里的正确做法是，你整天戴着VR头显的想法，我只是看不出这会发生。显示器，不像股票交易员那样摆放九个显示器。是的，即使你忘记了戴头显的重量和所有负担，人们似乎低估了它的本体感觉部分。仅仅是你看着现实世界并触摸事物的事实，比如你把手放在桌子上，你的桌子是……
real and it's right there you know i think um i mean maybe there's all sorts of tricks they could do with you know like neural radiance fields and all these things like actually recreate your desk and have it be sort of like so accurate that when you put your hand on it in vr you feel the same way but um but yeah i'm a little bit you know skeptical're just going to wear it all day. I think what you'll what you'll want is. You know, everyone on the team gets a headset. It's you know, it's probably cheaper than monitor at this point. Right. It's only like 300 bucks.
真实的，它就在那里。我想，也许他们可以用神经辐射场（NeRF）和所有这些东西做各种技巧，实际上重建你的桌子，让它变得如此精确，以至于当你在VR中把手放在上面时，你感觉是一样的。但，是的，我有点怀疑你会整天戴着它。我认为你想要的是，团队中的每个人都戴上头显。它可能比显示器便宜。对吧？它只有300美元左右。
Like some monitors are three, four hundred dollars. So on which headset you thought. But OK, so you're like you're talking about Oculus headset. Yeah. I mean, it seems to me like Oculus is just has just dominated. To be honest, I haven't even heard of any of the other headsets in a long time. I know there's the HTC Vive. There's one from Steam.
有些显示器要三四百美元。所以取决于你指的是哪种头显。但好的，所以你在谈论Oculus头显。是的，在我看来，Oculus似乎已经占据了主导地位。老实说，我已经很久没听说过任何其他头显了。我知道有HTC Vive。还有一个来自Steam的。
Yep. So I was going to say the next year there's rumors that there will be a new valve index. There's the Apple Vision Pro rumored to come. Oh, that's right. So I didn't know where you were going with this, but, but, okay. You know, I've, I didn't even think about the Apple one, that one, uh, it's not out yet. Right. No next year. Okay. Um, maybe, yeah, but so I don't know as much about the hardware, but I think that there'll be some type of app and maybe it'll be, you know know heterogeneous where some people could
是的。所以我本来想说明年有传言说会有新的Valve Index。还有传言说Apple Vision Pro要来了。哦，对了。所以我不知道你要去哪里，但，好的。你知道，我甚至没想过苹果的那款，它还没发布，对吧？明年没有。好的。也许，是的，但我对硬件了解不多，但我认为会有某种应用程序，也许它是异构的，有些人可以在……
be on apple some people could be on on oculus um but it'll be a way where you know when you want to do something creative you maybe you want to record a song or or or go on the whiteboard or something like that you know you and and your co-workers can can do this on VR. And, uh, and then it's, it's sort of like all integrated back into the workplace where, you know, all your notes are in Slack. Everything, everybody said was like,
苹果上，有些人可以在Oculus上。但当你想做一些创造性的事情时，比如你想录制一首歌，或者去白板前写写画画，你和你的同事可以在VR中做这件事。然后，它被整合回工作场所，你的所有笔记都在Slack里。每个人说的每一句话……
you know, there's dictation. And so you get this, like this report afterwards, um, um, you know, along with the whiteboard and it's animated.
都有听写。所以你之后会得到这份报告，连同白板，而且它是动画的。
So you could kind of see, you know, how the whiteboard evolved over time. So yeah, I think there's going to be some kind of cool VR work meeting push. Okay. And then you talked about lowering AI training costs, improved efficiency. So not just adding more and more parameters to your models, but focusing on getting
所以你可以看到白板是如何随时间演变的。所以，是的，我认为会有某种很酷的VR工作会议推动。好的。然后你谈到了降低AI训练成本，提高效率。所以不仅仅是给你的模型增加越来越多的参数，而是专注于获得……
more bang for your buck and being able to train quicker iterate is that the is that the call there yeah that's right yep i think uh the cost is getting totally out of control the models keep getting bigger although that's starting to plateau but um you know now you're seeing these ensemble models like mistral put out one where they created an ensemble um of eight different other large language models and so um it's like a mixture of experts type approach so um so you have it's faster than running you know each of those eight models because you you get some synergy there but um but yeah i think the the the inference you know folks try to optimize the inference it's really difficult because the inference um you know so
更高的性价比，能够更快地训练和迭代，这就是你的观点吗？是的，没错。我认为成本完全失控了。模型越来越大，尽管这开始趋于平稳。但现在你看到了这些集成模型，比如Mistral发布了一个，他们创建了一个由八个其他大型语言模型组成的集成。所以，这是一种专家混合（MoE）方法。所以它比运行那八个模型中的每一个都要快，因为你获得了一些协同效应。但，是的，我认为推理，人们试图优化推理，这非常困难，因为推理……
many people have spent so much time on that so you know once the model is trained um you know go ahead going ahead and evaluating it um you know there's a bunch of folks working on that and they've made a lot of really good progress but i think the actual training part of it is something that has lagged behind and uh um there are talks of you know am, AMD kind of, you know, upping their software game and, and, you know, creating a real rival for Nvidia. I mean, that could drive some of the costs, some of the price down, but, but still, I think that most people I talk to, they're wasting the GPU hours. So, you know, they, you get these GPUs from, from AWS or, you know, Amazon web services or Google cloud platform, and they charge you per hour. And, you know, if you turn on the
很多人花了很多时间在那上面。所以一旦模型训练完成，继续评估它，有一群人在做那个，他们取得了很大进展。但我认为实际的训练部分是滞后的。有传言说AMD正在提升他们的软件实力，创造一个真正的Nvidia竞争对手。我的意思是，这可能会降低一些成本，降低一些价格。但即便如此，我认为我交谈过的大多数人都在浪费GPU时间。所以，你从AWS或谷歌云平台获得这些GPU，他们按小时收费。如果你打开……
GPU machine and you don't use it, you're still paying per hour for, for the whole thing. Um, and, and in many of these cases, you know, know the the program is designed so that you know loading the data is so slow that you're only using like five percent of the gpu but you're paying for all of it um and so yeah this is something that we're just we're gonna have to fix as an industry all right and then uh you had risk v but i don't i don't know how to get you to make a bold a bold claim there well you know i've been trying to get my hands on uh basically like a raspberry pi equivalent but in risk v and they're still really expensive so um i just i think that with all the geopolitics stuff around you know the the intellectual property and everything i just feel like
GPU机器而不使用它，你仍然要为整个过程按小时付费。在许多情况下，程序设计得使得加载数据太慢，以至于你只使用了GPU的5%，但你却为所有这些付费。所以，是的，这是我们作为一个行业必须解决的问题。好的，然后你有RISC-V，但我不知道怎么让你做出一个大胆的声明。好吧，你知道，我一直试图弄到一个相当于树莓派但基于RISC-V的东西，它们仍然非常昂贵。所以，我只是觉得，随着围绕知识产权的所有地缘政治问题，我只是觉得……
something's going to open up there but i have to confess i know very little about that side of it it just feels like there's a lot of energy there we have a benefit of live chat we're getting feedback that it's risk five and wikipedia agrees it's risk five so okay wait where are you seeing the live chat oh in the general room uh so okay we'll use ai to go back and auto edit all of this so we're not yeah all right so so i have i guess like first i'll make some ai ones i think next year we're going to see someone claim to have uh gotten agi and it's going to unleash like a little bit of a debate about what does that actually mean like what is what is I think some people feel that means like sentience like oh it has some ongoing consciousness and like continuity to itself where you know right now we have like a look back where and and you can correct me if I'm wrong I might be misunderstanding but today like
那里会有什么东西出现，但我得承认我对那方面了解很少，只是觉得那里有很多能量。我们有实时聊天的优势，我们收到的反馈是它是RISC-V，维基百科也同意是RISC-V，所以好吧，等等，你在哪里看到实时聊天？哦，在通用聊天室里，好的，我们会用人工智能回去自动编辑所有这些内容，这样我们就不用……是的，好吧，所以我想我首先会做一些人工智能方面的预测。我认为明年我们会看到有人声称已经实现了通用人工智能（AGI），这将引发一场关于这到底意味着什么的辩论。我认为有些人觉得这意味着某种感知能力，比如它具有某种持续的意识和自我连续性，而你知道，现在我们只有一种回顾机制，如果你错了可以纠正我，我可能理解错了，但今天……
you talk to chat GPT it can only remember a certain number of tokens before basically you know the tokens start falling off the back so agi at some level will be it's able to recall indefinitely and you know sort of shape itself going forward over time and sort of build on it but i i don't know i think someone's going to claim that it just has to be expert enough across enough domains and so it's oh it's creative and it's doing this you know we've reached agi so someone's going to claim it because i feel there's a lot of uh political zeitgeist and uh yeah you know just saying it and we're gonna have the debate we saw google put out some guidelines on what they think qualifies as agi or not as a as a you know trying to get in and shape and define it but i think that'll be sort of one thing i think another thing we'll see is uh a lot of people focus on this like code writing code suggestion i'm actually i don't know whatever maybe i'm i'm short side i think it will come eventually i actually think
你和ChatGPT对话时，它只能记住一定数量的token，之后token就会从后面开始丢失。所以AGI在某种程度上将能够无限期地回忆，并且随着时间的推移塑造自己，并在其基础上进行构建。但我不知道，我认为有人会声称它只要在足够多的领域内足够专业，比如它很有创造力，它正在做这些事情，你知道，我们已经达到了AGI。所以有人会声称这一点，因为我觉得有很多政治时代精神，仅仅是说出来，我们就会进行辩论。我们看到谷歌发布了一些关于他们认为什么才算AGI的指导方针，试图介入并定义它，但我认为这会是一件事。我认为我们还会看到的另一件事是，很多人专注于代码编写和代码建议。其实我不知道，也许我目光短浅，我认为它最终会到来，我实际上认为……
what will will be uh more impactful and i'll i'm gonna make a bet that someone will come out with this next year is you see a lot in summarization and so i think having something like when you do a you know a github you know pull request or whatever that having something that comes in and does you know basically like a expert level suggester peer reviewer so we always talk on this you know program or on this podcast a difficult and responsibility of everyone to you know doing a uh not super high latency peer review but what if your first peer review was sort of just like from an ai suggesting you know oh that's genius not not just in your review but actually across your entire code base i've looked at it done some sort of summarization and said you know hey it looks like you're
更具影响力的事情，我敢打赌明年会有人推出这个，那就是你在总结方面看到的很多东西。所以我认为，当你进行GitHub拉取请求（pull request）或类似操作时，拥有一个能够介入并基本上充当专家级建议者和同行评审员的东西。我们总是谈论这个节目或这个播客，每个人都有责任进行非高延迟的同行评审，但如果你的第一次同行评审只是来自人工智能的建议，比如“哦，那真是天才”，不仅是在你的评审中，而且实际上是在你的整个代码库中。我已经看过了，做了一些总结，并说“嘿，看起来你……”
duplicating a lot of code from this other module over here. Have you looked at just using that one instead or making it more extensible or flexible? I think that'd be super cool. I think someone's working on it. They're just not talking about it yet. Well, to be clear, I don't actually know that. No, I think you're right. I mean, it's a great idea.
正在从另一个模块复制大量代码。你有没有考虑过直接使用那个模块，或者让它更具可扩展性或灵活性？我觉得那会非常酷。我想有人正在研究它，只是他们还没谈论它。好吧，需要明确的是，我并不真的知道这一点。不，我想你是对的。我的意思是，这是一个很棒的主意。
And then my final sort of AI one is I think we're going to see video generation, but for memes. So everyone's sort of focused on this like deep fake. And, you know, I think that's happening in the high production value. I think someone's going to find the right, you know, tick talkable. OK, but I don't know how you say that. The right, you know, sort of easy. Everyone can just like go make the goofy videos.
然后我最后一个关于人工智能的预测是，我认为我们将看到视频生成，但用于制作表情包。所以每个人都专注于这种深度伪造（deep fake）。而且，我认为这在高制作价值领域正在发生。我认为有人会找到正确的、适合TikTok传播的内容。好吧，我不知道该怎么说。那种正确的、简单的东西。每个人都可以随手制作那些滑稽的视频。
They were a rage for a while. I think it was like Korea or something where they would they would do the like you know news reports with the little like avatars you know marching right but like imagine that but like you just type in the scene you know whatever and you know i want to make a joke like this and someone's delivering the punchline for you as like a cartoon character something like that something that is within striking distance of today but it hits like a nerve of like it's funny it's not like creepy you know it's kind of obviously fake but but it's still you know pretty funny yeah have you seen the uh the fake uh pixar like uh movie movies uh where it shows like the yeah it has like um trying to think of an example, but it looks like the cover of a Pixar movie. And, you know, the characters look like Pixar characters, but they're fake. Like people generated it with the Bing image generator. And yeah, there was one, it was like, it was like Texans. And it was a bunch of pixar children like holding holding ars and stuff
它们曾经风靡一时。我想是在韩国还是什么地方，他们会制作那种带有小头像的新闻报道，你知道，走来走去，但想象一下，你只需要输入场景，不管是什么，你想开个这样的玩笑，然后有人像卡通人物一样为你提供笑点，类似这样的东西。这在今天看来触手可及，但它触动了某种神经，比如它很有趣，并不令人毛骨悚然，你知道，它显然是假的，但仍然非常有趣。是的，你见过那些假的皮克斯电影吗？它展示了……它有……我在想一个例子，但它看起来像皮克斯电影的封面。而且，你知道，角色看起来像皮克斯角色，但它们是假的。就像人们用必应图像生成器生成的。是的，有一个，就像是德州人。那是一群拿着AR步枪之类的皮克斯小孩。
yeah i mean i mean i'm sure you can find like the the the level of tastefulness you know you can get whatever you want there but um but but yeah and so they actually looked really really good i mean you know i knew that it was fake just from the content but but the quality looked real um like it looked like a you know a professional person artist had made this parody nice so yeah i mean but video is a whole nother level maybe i'll push you a little bit on that like uh you know like what do you think it's going to be video or images or where are we at now with video generation? So from what I kind of like gather, I've not gone and tried them yet. I think there's a bunch that are fairly close, but I've seen some really, really awesome ones, but they
是的，我的意思是，我相信你可以找到那种品味水平，你可以在那里得到任何你想要的，但是……但是是的，它们看起来确实非常好。我的意思是，我知道它是假的，仅仅从内容上看，但质量看起来很真实。看起来像是一个专业的艺术家制作了这个模仿作品。不错，所以是的，我的意思是，但视频是另一个层面。也许我会在这方面逼你一下，比如你认为明年会是视频还是图像，或者我们现在在视频生成方面处于什么阶段？所以据我所知，我还没有去尝试过它们。我认为有一堆相当接近了，但我看到了一些非常、非常棒的，但它们……
require you to still like start with a good template, like a blender, you know, sort of render and it doesn't have to be super precise or sort of drawing and getting there so i think my understanding is part of it is the sort of continuity so like if you wanted to make a scene right from like a movie or even for memes like you need characters that you can sort of cut away and cut back to and like they're not just some new complete random right so how do you sort of like give that guidance and and have the ai sort of keep we talked about that that sort of look back it needs the continuity across the entire you know clip that it sort of knows all the moving pieces whether they're on screen or off and so i think images are kind of i don't want to say like already there but you can go in and you can get like if you see the pictures coming out now with
仍然需要你从一个好的模板开始，比如Blender渲染，它不需要非常精确，或者绘图，然后达到那个程度。所以我认为我的理解是，其中一部分是某种连续性。所以如果你想从电影中制作一个场景，或者即使是为表情包制作，你也需要可以剪辑出去再剪回来的角色，而不是一些全新的、完全随机的东西。所以你如何提供那种指导，并让AI保持……我们谈到了那种回顾机制，它需要整个片段的连续性，它需要知道所有的移动部件，无论它们是在屏幕上还是屏幕外。所以我认为图像已经……我不想说已经完全实现了，但你可以进去，你可以得到……如果你看到现在出来的图片……
people it's always that i still see this oh you can tell it's ai you can tell it's not ai because the person has five fingers on each hand and i'm like oh i feel like oh they fix that yeah like all that stuff is so fixed it's really ambiguous at this point when you get a picture especially because it's blended if you look at like photoshop uh in in the public app now has you you draw a little lasso and type in what you want and it'll put it in there. So it becomes this very difficult, like, you know, what's real versus fake, I think. Have you ever been to thispersondoesnotexist.com?
人，我总是看到这个，“哦，你可以看出它是AI，你可以看出它不是AI，因为那个人每只手有五个手指”，我就想，哦，我觉得他们修复了那个。是的，所有这些东西都修复得很好。在这一点上，当你得到一张图片时，它真的很模糊，特别是如果它是混合的。如果你看像Photoshop，现在的公共应用程序里，你画一个小套索，输入你想要的，它就会把它放进去。所以我认为，这变得非常困难，比如，什么是真的，什么是假的。你去过thispersondoesnotexist.com吗？
A long time ago. Is it updated? Do they keep adding new versions? I mean, these people look like they exist. I mean, it's just solved um i mean i'm not an expert but like yeah i mean all of these people look totally real you know what actually what gives their way is the background but the person's face if you had if you had just cropped out just uh silhouetted out the background the person's face looks totally real there was
很久以前了。它更新了吗？他们一直在添加新版本吗？我的意思是，这些人看起来确实存在。我的意思是，这只是解决了……我的意思是，我不是专家，但是的，所有这些人看起来都完全真实。你知道，实际上是什么暴露了他们吗？是背景，但如果你的脸……如果你只是剪掉了背景，只留下了轮廓，那个人的脸看起来完全真实。有……
i'm not i'm not big on like youtuber personality people but i think i i'm gonna i'm gonna try i think it's peter mckinnon had a uh he's like a you know famous for doing photography stuff he's anyways he had a video where the users submitted uh using kind of this photoshop tool where they either extended the background or they started with a picture but then they edited it in some way like inserting a shed inserting a bison like whatever so they would give him a picture and people would send them in he wouldn't see him before and he would get i forget some number of seconds you know 20 seconds 30 seconds to look at the picture on his computer and figure out which parts were fake and which parts were real and of course you know he's he's a like if he zoomed in
我不太喜欢那种YouTuber个性的人，但我想我会尝试一下。我想是Peter McKinnon，他以做摄影相关的东西而闻名。无论如何，他有一个视频，用户提交了使用这种Photoshop工具的作品，他们要么扩展了背景，要么从一张图片开始，然后以某种方式编辑它，比如插入一个棚子，插入一头野牛，随便什么。所以他们会给他一张图片，人们会发给他，他之前没见过，他会得到……我忘了是多少秒，你知道，20秒、30秒，在电脑上看着那张图片，找出哪些部分是假的，哪些部分是真的。当然，你知道，他是一个……如果他放大……
and really thought about it or he knew knew the location, he would probably know. But in general, he had a really hard time because, you know, you just don't know. It was like, oh, these entire mountains in this beautiful, rocky, you know, landscape or Swiss Alps, it's just completely fake. It was actually just somebody's backyard. And so it's really difficult at the level these tools are getting when you start to blend between them. And I think for first glance stuff, again, that sort of Instagram, TikTok, whatever, you know, just passing by how much content you consume.
并且真正思考它，或者他知道那个地点，他可能会知道。但总的来说，他感到非常困难，因为你就是不知道。就像，“哦，这些美丽的、岩石嶙峋的景观或瑞士阿尔卑斯山中的整座山脉，完全是假的。”实际上那只是某人的后院。所以当这些工具开始混合时，达到这种程度真的很难。我认为对于第一眼看到的东西，同样，那种Instagram、TikTok，无论什么，你只是路过，你消费了多少内容。
A lot of that's going to become sort of the quote unquote airbrushed. It's going to become augmented in this way. But I think the next step is where you don't even need, like you said, the background, right? You don't even need that. It's just going to be completely end to end. I feel like that's so at hand. It's a bold bold move to guess images which is why i went video i think video is still not there yet it's very difficult to get stable looks like it was shot in a video camera yeah that makes sense um no that's fine any other predictions for 2024
很多内容将成为所谓的“精修”。它将以这种方式被增强。但我认为下一步是你甚至不需要，就像你说的，背景，对吧？你甚至不需要那个。它将完全是端到端的。我觉得这触手可及。猜测图像是一个大胆的举动，这就是为什么我选择了视频。我认为视频还没有达到那个水平，很难获得看起来像用摄像机拍摄的稳定画面。是的，这说得通。嗯，没关系。对2024年还有其他预测吗？
so let's see let me see if i have a recap so you're saying oh uh a um a peer reviewer ai peer reviewer yeah we'll also throw in ai like document writer you know like like uh documenting their functions and stuff i feel like that's that would kind of come for free if you had the other one um and uh oh and um the video generation like a tiktok type thing with generative ai yeah any do you want to do a third prediction sure i'll do i think i had one more but i've already forgot it i think the third one will make a space we always like to make a space prediction because i i'm bullish i think there's a big unlock that can happen if we can get to space really cheap like lots of mass to orbit and i feel there's a lot of different uh sort of companies working in the space now a lot of them have really cool technologies a lot of the demos of pieces
让我们看看，让我看看我是否有一个总结。所以你是说，一个AI同行评审员，是的，我们还会加上AI文档编写，比如记录他们的函数之类的。我觉得如果你有了前一个，这就像是免费赠送的。还有，视频生成，像TikTok那种带有生成式AI的东西。是的，你想做第三个预测吗？当然，我会做。我想我还有一个，但我已经忘了。我认为第三个会是太空。我们总是喜欢做一个太空预测，因为我很看好。我认为如果我们能以非常便宜的价格进入太空，比如大量的质量进入轨道，就会有一个巨大的解锁。我觉得现在有很多不同的公司在太空领域工作，他们中的许多人有非常酷的技术，很多部件的演示……
of their systems this year uh not just basex with uh you know their stuff that they're they're they're testing out uh in um in texas but also the what is that spin launch and uh people who are uh just building various like stage one or stage two components i think there's a there's a lot of really cool stuff so i think next year we're going to see people reaching orbit with a lot of these test platforms and uh you know sort of start a new space race because if you can get things up there and you can get fuel up and refuel all of a sudden i mean they talk about that like bringing one asteroid back i don't think we'll see an asteroid come back you know for the next 10 years but you start to get to where a lot of interesting things become possible if it's super
他们的系统今年……不仅仅是SpaceX，还有他们在德克萨斯州测试的东西，还有那个SpinLaunch，以及那些正在建造各种第一级或第二级组件的人。我认为有很多非常酷的东西。所以我认为明年我们将看到人们用许多这些测试平台到达轨道，并开启一场新的太空竞赛。因为如果你能把东西送上去，你能把燃料送上去并进行补给，突然之间……我的意思是，他们谈论带回一颗小行星。我不认为我们在未来10年内会看到小行星被带回来，但你开始达到很多有趣的事情成为可能的程度，如果……
cheap to get things into orbit and vice versa, get things from orbit down onto earth. You know, I think a lot of stuff we talk about, one of the problems for electric vehicles is a lot of the materials that go into them are scarce or ecologically impactful to mine. But if it's really easy to get, you know, things up into orbit and asteroids into orbit or, you know, things out to asteroids to mine them it could be pretty straightforward to it's probably much more ecological to sort of bring down a cargo box i don't always say that of lithium than it is to mine lithium out of the earth and so also you can have you know extending i don't know if the lithium isn't someone's going
把东西送入轨道非常便宜，反之亦然，把东西从轨道带回地球。你知道，我认为我们谈论的很多东西，电动汽车面临的问题之一是，很多制造它们的材料要么稀缺，要么开采起来对生态有影响。但如果把东西送入轨道，把小行星送入轨道，或者把东西送到小行星上去开采它们变得非常容易，那可能就相当直接了。把一箱锂带下来可能比从地球上开采锂更符合生态。所以你也可以有……我不知道如果锂不是……有人会……
to fact check me i don't know if that was a good one to pick, but a lot of these metals that are in asteroids and stuff, I think become accessible. And so I think that's why I'm bullish on it overall, but I think next year we're going to see a lot of the, you know, people building these sort of test platforms. And I think there's probably a lot in stealth mode because if we can see all these that are out in public,
去核实我的事实，我不知道这是否是一个好的选择，但很多存在于小行星中的金属，我认为变得可以获取了。所以我认为这就是我总体上看好它的原因，但我认为明年我们将看到很多建造这些测试平台的人。而且我认为可能有很多处于隐身模式，因为如果我们能看到所有这些公开的东西……
I think there's a lot more that are keeping their sort of head to the ground and just focused on working. once they start launching you can't really keep that secret anymore or less they look like sort of weapon so uh they have to become public so i think we're gonna see a lot more stealth uncoverings again i don't know any secret details there uh but i think uh getting to orbit for a lot of these uh startups is going to be a thing for next year wow it's a bold prediction yeah we'll go that all right um all right so we'll before we get into questions i'll talk about our first winner our first winner is frederick jay uh in germany i won't say your last name, Frederick, but you won a t-shirt.
我认为还有更多的人保持低调，只专注于工作。一旦他们开始发射，你就无法再保密了，除非它们看起来像武器。所以它们必须公开。所以我认为我们将看到更多隐身状态的揭露。再说一次，我不知道任何秘密细节，但我认为对于许多初创公司来说，明年进入轨道将是一件大事。哇，这是一个大胆的预测。是的，我们会去做的。好吧，在我们进入问题之前，我会谈谈我们的第一位获胜者。我们的第一位获胜者是德国的Frederick J。我不会说出你的姓氏，Frederick，但你赢得了一件T恤。
So I'll be reaching out to you. Isn't it? Is it Guten Tag? Doesn't that mean like welcome? I know a little, a very tiny amount of German. But anyways, Frederick, thank you so much for being a patron. And I will be in contact with you
所以我到时候会联系你。不是吗？是Guten Tag吗？那不是欢迎的意思吗？我知道一点点，非常少量的德语。但无论如何，Frederick，非常感谢你成为赞助人。我会和你联系……
to get a t-shirt, to give a t-shirt um all right and with that said our first question is um from don on discord he says i'm an early career dev been working for about three years i'm finding my current role and he put in parentheses fang so for people don't know it's what facebook amazon apple netflix google um at one of those companies um that i'm part of a huge machine all the work i do is liaising with other teams rather than shipping code um i have an offer from a startup where i'd be shipping a lot more stuff um you know he's worried that at his uh current position he's missing out a lot of lessons uh just because it's just so much so much discussion not that much uh you know working on your craft
去拿一件T恤，送一件T恤。好吧，话虽如此，我们的第一个问题来自Discord上的Don。他说：“我是一名职业生涯早期的开发人员，工作了大约三年。我发现我目前的角色——他在括号里写了FANG，所以对于不知道的人来说，它是Facebook、亚马逊、苹果、Netflix、谷歌——在这些公司之一，我是巨大机器的一部分。我所做的所有工作都是与其他团队联络，而不是发布代码。我有一个初创公司的录用通知，在那里我会发布更多的东西。”你知道，他担心在他目前的位置上，他错过了很多课程，仅仅是因为讨论太多，而没有太多致力于打磨你的手艺……
and writing code um but he's also where he's undervaluing the soft skills that he's doing right now um how do you think about the trade-off between coding and soft skills? Patrick, how do you feel about that trade-off? Oh, man, I'm taking off guard because that's not where I thought the question was going. So I was prepping myself. Well, maybe I'll take a crack at it. I mean, I think, you know, man, so I don't know if this is going to be a distraction or diversion or not, but at some point in my career, I realized that not having very good soft skills and not being really aware of what was going on in the company, in the news, like the programming news, but that was really hurting me. You know, at some point I realized that like I was doing a lot of stuff that could have been done a lot easier if I had, you know, just been more aware. So for example, I mean,
和编写代码。但他也在担心他是否低估了自己现在正在做的软技能。你如何看待编码和软技能之间的权衡？Patrick，你对这种权衡有什么看法？哦，天哪，我被问住了，因为我没想到问题会往这个方向发展。所以我一直在做准备。好吧，也许我会试着回答一下。我的意思是，我认为，天哪，我不知道这是否会成为一种干扰或转移，但在我职业生涯的某个阶段，我意识到没有很好的软技能，并且对公司里正在发生的事情、新闻，比如编程新闻，没有真正的了解，这真的伤害了我。你知道，在某个时刻，我意识到我做了很多事情，如果我……只是更了解情况，这些事情本来可以做得更容易。所以例如，我的意思是……
this isn't exactly what happened, but imagine, you know, you spent all this time trying to figure out a way to really quickly get data from a CSV file. And so like you're writing all this crazy C++ code or something to like quickly like seek through this CSV file and pull rows. And then someone comes to you and says, oh, there's there's this thing called a database. And, you know, you just put it in the database and they've done it all for you. It's that kind of thing where, you know, I realized at some point in my life, I realized that like, yeah, I should actually, you know,
这不完全是发生的事情，但想象一下，你花了所有这些时间试图想出一种方法来真正快速地从CSV文件中获取数据。所以你写了所有这些疯狂的C++代码之类的东西，来快速地在CSV文件中查找并提取行。然后有人走过来对你说，“哦，有一个东西叫数据库。”而且，你知道，你只要把它放进数据库，他们就已经为你做好了所有事情。就是那种情况，你知道，我在我生命中的某个时刻意识到，是的，我实际上应该……
read more and talk to more people and spend like a little bit less time just like coding absolutely everything from scratch. So I do think that you know personally i kind of was too far on one end of it um now on the other end you do spend a lot of time in big companies um you know kind of like doing a lot of social work with a lot of different teams and coordinating and all of that and that does take an extraordinary amount of time. I mean, there's, there's a lot more training time at bigger companies, uh, you know, and these are sort of like these soft skills
多读点书，多和人交流，少花点时间从零开始编写所有东西。所以我确实认为，我个人在某种程度上走得太远了。现在在另一方面，你在大公司确实花了很多时间，你知道，有点像和许多不同的团队做很多社交工作，进行协调等等，这确实需要花费大量的时间。我的意思是，大公司有更多的培训时间，你知道，这些是某种软技能……
training courses, like effective communication and all these things that, that you might have to take. And, um, um, actually the bigger issue is that the code, you probably do spend a decent amount of time coding, even at a bigger company, but that coding works going to be more like integration work and you're not going to be building as much from scratch. So I do think there's, what is your immediate team and manager like? done do you look back and say oh really that's really cool that we built that or or is it just you know turning turning a dial or turning a cog in this machine that you're not they're totally disconnected from so i think those are the big things um and and uh yeah i'd be less concerned about um whether there's more or less soft skills versus coding. But Patrick, what's your thoughts? All right.
培训课程，比如有效沟通和所有这些你可能必须参加的事情。而且，实际上更大的问题是代码，你可能确实花了不少时间编码，即使在大公司，但那些编码工作更像是集成工作，你不会从零开始构建那么多东西。所以我确实认为，你的直接团队和经理是什么样的？Don，你回过头来看，会说“哦，真的，我们构建那个真的很酷”吗？还是说，你只是在转动这个机器里的一个旋钮或齿轮，而你与它完全脱节？所以我认为这些是重要的事情。而且，是的，我会不太担心软技能和编码哪个更多或更少。但Patrick，你怎么看？好的。
Thank you for buying me time. No, it was a good answer. I guess, not to cop out, I don't think there's a singular correct answer. I mentioned this before, but I think the same thing applies here. This isn't something that is you set a dial between the two soft skills and sort of programming skills and you leave it there. That's, that is definitely the wrong answer regardless of where you set the dial.
谢谢你为我争取时间。不，这是一个很好的回答。我想，不是为了逃避，我不认为有一个单一的正确答案。我之前提到过这一点，但我认为同样的事情也适用于这里。这不是一个你在软技能和编程技能之间设置一个刻度盘然后就放在那里的问题。那绝对是错误的答案，无论你把刻度盘设置在哪里。
And I think depending on where you are in your career, what situation calls for, but okay. Specifically at a Fang company, I will say i'll give that caveat first uh having been at two of the letters in the fang company um jason can one-up me there but that's fine i will say that soft skills are often in short supply and so having them yeah that's true a critical critical team member but when it comes time for promotion you're being able to point to specific innovative pieces of code or integrations that you did they're much more
而且我认为取决于你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，情况需要什么，但好吧。特别是在FANG公司，我会说，我会先给出那个警告。在FANG公司的两个字母里待过……Jason可以在这方面胜过我，但这没关系。我会说软技能通常供不应求，所以拥有它们……是的，那是真的，是一个关键的团队成员。但当涉及到晋升时，你能够指出你所做的具体的创新代码片段或集成，它们要……得多。
defensible it is very very hard for your manager your director to go to another director or manager and say this person is such a, such a collaborator, they are such a, you know, ability to just find the right problem to like, those things are all true. And they're all necessary. And they help you get the results and the leverage. So you, you really have to be clutch at them. But if they come at the cost of being able to point to like, you're helping everyone else do their amazing coding you're very high risk of having all those people you help get promoted before you do so in a purely selfish not best thing for the project now helping the project succeed is ultimately good for you but like
这是非常非常难的，让你的经理、你的总监去对另一位总监或经理说，“这个人是一个如此好的合作者，他们有如此……能力去找到正确的问题来……”那些事情都是真的。而且它们都是必要的。它们帮助你获得结果和杠杆作用。所以你真的必须在这些方面表现出色。但如果它们是以牺牲你能够指出你正在帮助其他人完成他们惊人的编码为代价的，你很有可能让所有你帮助过的人在你之前获得晋升。所以在纯粹自私的、对项目不是最好的情况下，现在帮助项目成功最终对你有好处，但就像……
i think i've suffered from this before doing exactly these things running around helping people doing integrations making sure and then myself not being able to point to specific code contributions has hurt me at FANG companies. So that probably has different dynamics on different teams and maybe even different of the letters in the company and at a startup. But in those companies, I will say you have to be cognizant that you have to get the right work at the right time, which is a soft skill, but being able to execute and write that code that everyone agrees is, is, you know, chef's kiss, right? That, that it doesn't have to be a lot of code. It has to be, you have to point to specific code that no one else was writing that you
我想我以前因为做这些事情而受过苦，到处帮助别人，做集成，确保……然后我自己却无法指出具体的代码贡献，这在FANG公司伤害了我。所以这在不同的团队中可能有不同的动态，甚至在公司不同的字母部门和初创公司中也可能不同。但在这些公司里，我会说你必须意识到你必须在正确的时间做正确的工作，这是一种软技能，但能够执行并编写每个人都同意是……你知道，“厨师之吻”的代码，对吧？那……它不需要是大量的代码。它必须是，你必须指出没有人写的、你正在写的具体代码。那是……点燃火箭引擎的方法。所以，平衡这种软技能、硬技能、软技能、硬技能的平衡，填补你的管道，我认为这本身就是一种技能。而且这真的很难，因为你永远不知道正确答案。
were writing. That's the, the way to sort of light the engine on the rocket ship. And so, um so playing that balance, the fiddle of moving between soft skill, hard skill, soft skill, hard skill, filling your pipe, I think that's a skill in itself. And it is really hard because you never know the right answer.
甚至在回顾时，你也不知道你是否把刻度盘设置正确了。是的，是的。我同意所有这些。这非常有道理。另一件事是，在我看来，初创公司和FANG公司之间最大的区别是。在初创公司的情况下，每个人都在承担这种巨大的集体风险，要么每个人都赢，要么每个人都在公司里输。所以这创造了一种……某种同志情谊，你知道，这自然地创造了这种……你知道，你们都在一起赢或一起输的感觉。但在FANG公司，那并不是真的。
And not even in retrospect, do you really learn whether or not you had the dial set correctly? Yep, yep. I agree with all of that. That makes a ton of sense. The other thing is, you know, the big difference, in my opinion, between a startup and a fan company is. In the case of the startup, everyone's taking this gigantic collective risk and either everyone wins or everyone loses at the company um and so that creates um you know a sort of sense of camaraderie um you know that that that naturally creates this this like a sense of of uh you know you're all winning or losing together. But in the FANG companies, that's not really true.
大多数人都在被评估，他们作为个人受到激励。所以你可以在一个完全失败的项目上获得晋升。只要你没有被解雇，只要你只是被调到FANG公司的其他项目上，那么，你就……
Most people are being evaluated and they're being incentivized as an individual. So you could get promoted on a project that completely fails. And as long as you aren't laid off, as long as you're just put onto some other project in that thing company, then, then you did,
你做得很好，而初创公司则不同。如果初创公司失败了，每个人的股票都会归零。好吧。所以我们有一个三部分的问题。实际上，这是三个非常独特、非常棒的问题，所以我们将逐一讨论。第一个是……
you did, you did great versus like the startup. If the startup fails, everyone's stock goes to zero. Um, all right. So we have a three part question. Um, actually these are three very distinct really great questions so we'll just go through go through them one by one um the first one is
你认为目前对AI的炒作将如何以及何时结束？这是一个好问题。我的意思是，这确实感觉像是2012年AlexNet和所有那些东西重演。我认为，这是我的想法，OpenAI的Q-Star不会奏效。我相当怀疑。你知道，总的来说，你知道，我有一个理论，即保密的东西在研究方面通常不会奏效。你知道，那种会有什么大揭秘的想法。所以，好吧。看看ChatGPT，例如。所以，你知道，Facebook在ChatGPT之前有一个东西叫Galactica，它可以编写研究论文，而且……它工作得相当好，而且它会编写……它会根据一个主题生成研究论文。所以ChatGPT是建立在……
how and when do you think the current hype for ai will end um it's a good question. I mean, it does feel like 2012 all over again with AlexNet and all of that. I think that, here's what I think, and star thing from open AI is not going to work. I'm pretty skeptical. You know, in general, you know, I have this theory that things that are secretive usually don't work when it comes to research. You know, the idea that like there's going to be some big reveal. So, you know, OK. Look at chat GBT, for example. So, you know, Facebook had something that predated chat GBT called a Galactica where it would write research papers and, um, it worked pretty well and, and it would write, you know, it would, it would generate research papers based on a topic um and so chat gbt is built on the
所有这些其他模型的基础上的，对吧？OpenAI做得非常好的一点是将该技术与普通人连接起来，营销得非常好，你知道，在它产生幻觉和生成虚假内容时处理后果，你知道，适当地处理这些后果，等等。但是，你知道，所有这些事情都是渐进的。总的来说，一切都比人们希望你相信的要渐进得多。所以这种想法，合并……你知道，某种策略优化，你知道，做出决定，无论是在棋盘游戏中还是在现实世界中做出决定，如果你……如果你有一种方法可以做到这一点，你知道，将它与语言理解连接起来……你知道，我觉得第一个真正做到这一点的尝试……我的意思是，我们有Cicero和一些针对某些棋盘游戏的方法，但所有这些都是……你知道，非常……
shoulders of all of these other bottles right um the thing that open ai did really well is connect connect that technology to everyday people market it really well um you know handle the fallout when it does hallucinate and generate fake things, you know, handle that fallout appropriately and, and, and all of that. Um, but it was, you know, all of these things are incremental. Um, in general, everything is much more incremental than people would like to have you believe. Um, and so this idea of, um, merging, you know, kind of policy optimization, you know, making decisions, whether it's in a board game or decisions in the real world, if you, if you have a way to do that, um, you know, connecting that with language understanding um you know i feel like the first approach to really do that i mean we have cicero and some of these approaches for some board games but all of these are you know very
针对棋盘游戏的。而且正如我们从AlphaGo所知道的那样，你知道，谷歌无法将AlphaGo背后的计算机、代码和所有东西拿来用于交易股票或什么东西，或者我不知道，用它来做任何其他事情。所以，你知道，我怀疑即使Cicero背后的人去了OpenAI，我也怀疑这个Q-Star东西会……真的成为一场巨大的革命。它可能是，但，但我很怀疑。所以我认为当人们意识到实际上使用这波新AI在现实世界中做事情比每个人想象的要难得多时，我认为在那一点上，炒作就会结束。它将成为另一个周期的一部分。最终，我们将找到一种优雅、强大的方式来进行策略优化。想象一下，你将如何将这些大型语言模型与机器人技术结合起来，例如？有人会以一种优雅的方式破解它，然后那将是下一个炒作曲线，但……但我认为这个炒作曲线会在人们意识到它在说话和提取数据方面相当不错时死亡……
specific to to board games and as we know from alpha go you know google wasn't able to take the computer the the the code and all that behind alpha go and use it to like trade stocks or something or i don't know use it to do anything else so so you know i i'm skeptical that like even though the people behind cicero went to open ai i'm skeptical that this q star thing is going to um really be a huge revolution it could be but, but I'm skeptical. And so I think when people realize that actually using this new wave of AI to do things in the real world is a lot harder than everyone thinks, I think at that point, the hype will end. And it'll be part of another cycle. And eventually, we will figure out an elegant, powerful way to do policy optimization. Imagine, how would you combine these large language models with robotics, for example? Someone's going to crack that in an elegant way, and then that'll be the next type curve but uh but i think this hype curve will die when people realize that it's it's pretty good for speaking and pulling data and
它在搜索和相关性方面很好，但对于实际做事情来说很困难。你呢，Patrick？是的，所以我的意思是，我想这是一个简单的问题，比如……也许它已经结束了……或者接下来。我认为其中有几个……人类因素的东西，这只是进入了这一点，即在相对性能指标中，每一次新的OpenAI发布，它不一定是同样的绝对改进，但在相对基础上，它下降了，对吧？所以从GPT2到GPT3或什么的飞跃，它感觉如此强大，因为它看起来如此酷，但随着时间的推移，每一个增量，你必须实际上为了获得同样的百分比增长，你的绝对增长必须显著增加。而且他们已经说了，“嘿，听着，我们已经达到了参数缩放的终点。”谁知道其中有多少真相，你知道，公关成分，但我认为我们看到了这一点，即我们没有看到同样的飞跃，前进已经感觉不那么大了。话虽如此，我认为将这一点正常化，你提到了搜索目的，Jason，比如能够……甚至从前谷歌搜索引擎，它们字面上是在做模糊字符串匹配……我的意思是，我知道还有其他的……到能够给出与你的问题大致一致的东西并得到答案，至少你知道，下一步是编写它。更糟糕的是，我问了……OpenAI ChatGPT关于某个计算机科学的问题，我不知道它叫什么，我不知道在谷歌中打印的正确……
engaging it's good for search and relevance type stuff but it's difficult for actually doing things what about you patrick yeah so i mean i guess it's an easy question which is like uh maybe it already has um or next and i think the there's a couple of like human factors things that just go into that which is in a relative performance you know metric the each new open ai release isn't it it can be the same sort of like absolute improvement but on a relative basis that goes down right and so the the leap from gpt2 to gpt3 or whatever it it feels so much more powerful because it just it just seems so much cooler but over time each one of those increments you have to actually to give the same percentage increase your absolute increase has to be significantly more and they've already said hey listen like
搜索词，所以我只是解释了它，问题的本质。它没能帮到我，但它确实给了我一堆与我所说相匹配的相关东西，而我本来无法输入……比如，我有一个图，我试图计算这个或那个的邻居数量，你知道，以这种特定的方式，谷歌只会匹配“计算图中邻居的数量”之类的，对吧？并给我一些邻接矩阵的算法，你知道，计算之类的。所以我认为它已经在这里了。但我认为炒作已经……人们，人们的注意力跨度像蚊子一样。我不知道。我觉得炒作已经死了。
we've reached the end of parameter scaling we know who knows how much truth there you know pr there is to that but i think we're seeing that which is we're not seeing the same the leap forward already doesn't feel as big that said i think normalizing this out you kind of mentioned for search purposes jason like being able to even going from pre i'll call it pre-google search engines where they literally were doing like fuzzy string matching i mean i know there were others to being able to give just something vaguely in line with your question and get back answer at least you know the next step to writing it even worse i was asking you know open ai chat gpt the question about some computer science problem and i didn't know what it was called i didn't know the right
所以现在只是一群人将开始工作，整合当前的能力。问题是，就像你说的，如果你回到以前的AI繁荣，它们从未真正体现在以一种超级、超级有意义的方式在日常生活中使用。问题是，当前这一批，给予12、18、24个月的时间，它们会成为一场新的工业革命吗？对吧。当然，也许在那之后还会继续有炒作周期。但它们会真正产生有意义的改变吗？我认为还有待观察。
search terms of print in google so i just like explained it the nature of the problem uh it failed me but it did give me a bunch of like relevant things that matched what i was saying whereas i wouldn't have been able to put like i I have a graph, and I'm trying to like, count the number of you know, neighbors of this or that, you know, in this particular way, Google would have just matched like, count number of neighbors in a graph or something, right? And give me some algorithm for adjacency matrix, you know, counting anyways. So I think it's already here. But I think the hype is already like, people, people have the attention span of a gnat. I don't know. I feel like the hype is already dead.
是的。是的。这很有道理。好吧。你觉得节目的现状如何？明年有什么你想改变的吗，Patrick？AI Patrick，哦，天哪，你知道那是个好主意。我们应该在节目中加入某种AI。我的意思是，作为技术专家和AI人士，把一些……
So now it's just a bunch of people are going to get to work integrating the current capabilities. The question, like you said, if you go back to previous AI booms, they never really manifested and being used in everyday life in a super, super meaningful way. The question is whether the current batch given 12, 18, 24 months, are they going to be like a new industrial revolution or not? Right. And sure, maybe they'll continue to be hype cycles after that. But will they actually affect meaningful change? I think it's yet to be seen.
类型的AI放进去，确实对我们有好处。我一直想做的一件事是语音到语音的翻译。我认为Facebook有一个……我忘了它叫什么了。Facebook有这个模型，他们做语音到语音的翻译。所以换句话说……
Yep. Yep. That makes sense. All right. What do you think about the current shape of the show is there anything you'd like to change next year patrick ai patrick oh man you know that's a great idea we should have uh some type of of ai in the show i mean it really behooves us as technologists and as AI people to put some
你可以获取嵌入，然后他们再次将其提取出来，对吧？但用不同的语言。所以你实际上可以拿走我们的一集，而且……你知道，你可以转换它，这样我们就在说……葡萄牙语之类的，但它有我们的语调和一切。好吧，那个……我是在开玩笑。我认为我们今年确实改变了节目，所以我想尝试……你知道，Jason和我都很忙，所以我认为我们采用了一种稍微不同的格式，而且是的，我实际上认为这是……我会说这对我们长期来说更可持续。所以是的，我对这个很满意，而且它已经持续了很长时间。我听其他的播客，他们说，“哦，你知道，这是我们的第八年或第九年。”我就想，“哇，他们已经持续了很长时间。”等等，等等。嘿，等等，就像，我们比那更长。但我有点……它对我来说不真实。我不知道。这非常、非常奇怪。我对这个播客有一种非常奇怪的关系，我想。是的，完全。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，我们今年做的一件事，正如Patrick……
type of AI. One thing I've always wanted to do is the speech-to-speech translation. I think Facebook has a... I forgot what it's called. Facebook has this model where they do speech-to-speech translation. So in other words,
所暗示的那样，就是我们让它变得更轻松了。嗯，我们只是，你知道，我们上线，我们交谈，我不认为我们现在正在做。它真的很随意，也许明年我想以某种方式让更多的社区参与进来，但我没有明确的计划，但我对我们现在所做的事情感到满意，我们保持得相当随意。我认为当你在节目中有一位嘉宾时，那位嘉宾在你的节目上要么是为了推广某事，要么是为了推进一项事业，或者他们有一个目标。而且每当任何人有一个目标时，他们就有可能无法实现他们的目标。对吧。所以……而且它只是，你知道，没有人真正回来对我们说，“哦，我讨厌那个节目。我讨厌上你的节目。”像那样的事情什么也没发生。每一位嘉宾都……是的，完全正确。完全正确。
you can take embedding and then they pull it back out again right but in a different language so you can actually take one of our episodes and uh you know you can you can convert it so that we're speaking you know portuguese or something but it's it has our intonations and everything okay well that i was partly joking uh i think like we actually did change the show this year so i think trying you know jason and i are pretty busy so i think we've gone to a little bit of a different format and yeah i actually think this is uh i'll say more sustainable long term for us so yeah i'm i'm happy happy with this and uh it's been going a long time i listen to other podcasts podcasts, and they say, Oh, you know, this is our, you know, eighth year or ninth year. And I'm like, Wow, they've been going a long time. Now, wait a minute. Hey, wait, like, we got longer than that. But I kind of doesn't like it's not real to me. I don't know. It's very, it's very strange. I have a very strange relationship with this podcast, I guess. Yeah, totally. I mean, I think, you know, one thing we did this year, as Patrick
每一位嘉宾对我们都非常礼貌，但这确实……它确实增加了一点负担。如果Patrick和我只是，你知道，周一从床上滚下来，说“嘿，你知道，我们这周应该做个节目吗？”那会好得多、多、多。所以我们将坚持这种格式，至少在2024年的早期部分，看看进展如何。最后一个问题是，科技界有什么令人兴奋的事情即将发生吗？我想我们在开始时已经涵盖了这一点。但非常感谢Vitkosoft提出的问题。我们还要做另一次赠品吗？让我们做吧。所以下一个……
alluded to, is like, we just made it a little bit more effortless. Um, we just, you know, we get on, we talk, I don't think we're doing right now. It really casually, uh, maybe next year I'd like to somehow get more of the community involved, but I don't, I don't have any clear plans, but I'm happy with what we're doing right now where we're keeping it pretty casual. I think when you have a guest on the show, that guest is on your show to either promote something or to advance a cause or they have a goal. And anytime anyone has a goal, there's a chance that they don't meet their goal. Right. And so and so it just, you know, no one's really come back to us and said, Oh, I hated that show. I hated being on your show. Like nothing like that has happened. Every guest has been, yeah, exactly. Exactly.
正如所提到的，我们只是让它变得更轻松了一些。嗯，我们只是，你知道，我们上线，我们聊天，我不认为我们现在做得太正式。这真的很随意，嗯，也许明年我想以某种方式让更多的社区成员参与进来，但我没有，我没有任何明确的计划，但我对我们现在所做的感到满意，我们保持得相当随意。我认为当你邀请嘉宾上节目时，那位嘉宾上你的节目要么是为了宣传某事，要么是为了推进某项事业，或者他们有一个目标。而每当有人有目标时，就有可能无法实现他们的目标。对吧。所以，你知道，没有人真的回来对我们说，哦，我讨厌那个节目。我讨厌上你的节目。像那样的事情从来没有发生过。每一位嘉宾都，是的，完全正确。完全正确。
Every guest has been nothing but polite to us, but it does, it does kind of put a bit of a weight. It's much, much, much nicer if, uh, Patrick and I can just, you know, roll out of bed on Monday and say, Hey, you know, should we do a show this week? So we're going to stick with this format, at least for the early part of 2024 and see how it goes. Last question was anything exciting in tech coming up? I think we covered that in the beginning. But thank you so much, Vitkosoft, for your questions. Are we doing another giveaway? Let's do it. So the next
每一位嘉宾对我们都非常客气，但这确实，确实带来了一点压力。如果我和帕特里克周一能直接从床上爬起来说，嘿，你知道，我们这周要录节目吗？那会好得多，多得多。所以我们打算坚持这种形式，至少在2024年初是这样，看看效果如何。最后一个问题是科技界有什么令人兴奋的事情即将发生吗？我想我们在开头已经涵盖了这一点。但非常感谢Vitkosoft提出的问题。我们要再做一次赠品活动吗？让我们开始吧。所以下一个
person to get a t-shirt is Rob G. I don't have Rob's address, but I do have your email address. And so Rob, I will be in contact with you to get a t-shirt.
获得T恤的人是Rob G。我没有Rob的地址，但我有你的电子邮箱。所以Rob，我会联系你来领取T恤。
So congratulations Rob. and thank you so much for being a patron rob's been a patron for over a year so thank you rob nice uh i have a small small segue before we go into another question uh something that we we haven't talked about but has been really interesting uh is 3D printers. So we've talked briefly about 3D printers in the past. I think 3D printers are also sort of like coming into their own this year. So we didn't make, I didn't have a bold prediction about it, but I'm excited to see sort of what's going to happen with the quality and amount. Do you have a 3D printer, Jason? Yeah, I do. I actually, last Black Friday, I replaced my 3D printer jason yeah i do i actually last black friday i replaced my 3d
恭喜Rob，非常感谢你成为赞助人。Rob已经支持我们一年多了，谢谢你，Rob。在进入下一个问题之前，我有一个小小的过渡。我们之前没怎么聊过，但其实非常有趣的话题是3D打印机。我们过去简单讨论过3D打印机。我觉得3D打印机今年也算是迎来了属于它们的时代。我们虽然没有对此做出大胆的预测，但我很期待看到它们的质量和数量会有怎样的发展。Jason，你有3D打印机吗？有的。其实去年“黑色星期五”的时候，我换了一台3D打印机。
printer and now i have an ender s1 pro which i really enjoy nice nice i think we save it up for another episode to talk about but i recently i think i'll call it a gen 3 so i had a gen not a gen 0 like a rep rap like a know, do everything yourself from scratch. But I got on at Gen One, I'll call it, which was like you procured 2020 aluminum extrusion and you like screwed stuff together. And, you know, it's just like a kit. Yeah, I had one of those. Personal, I call that Gen One. Then Gen Two was like the ender.
现在我用的是Ender S1 Pro，我非常喜欢。不错，不错。我觉得我们可以留到以后再专门做一期节目来聊这个。但我最近——我称之为第三代吧——我之前用过不是第零代，不像那种RepRap，就是什么都得自己从零开始组装的。但我接触的是第一代，我称之为第一代，就是那种你买来2020铝型材，然后把东西拧在一起，就像个套件一样。是的，我以前也有一台。个人而言，我称之为第一代。然后第二代就像是Ender。
I had an ender. Yeah, it was great. Great. I'll say I think it's a clear Gen Three. I got a bamboo X1C. And yeah, we'll talk about in a future episode but it is it is fundamentally a different interaction than gen 1 and 2 and uh i printed so many things i've had exactly one issue once and i haven't like touched it like wow it's dude it's it's crazy so that's amazing this is the unlock and so it's just gonna
我有一台Ender。是的，它很棒。真的很棒。我觉得现在这台绝对是第三代。我买了一台拓竹（Bambu）X1C。是的，我们以后会专门聊聊它，但它与第一代和第二代的交互方式有着本质的区别。我打印了很多东西，只遇到过一次问题，之后就再也没管过它。哇，伙计，这太疯狂了。这真是太神奇了，这就是解锁了新体验，所以它肯定会
ripple out i think people have been a little burned so it's gonna take a little time but i think uh yeah i think there's a revolution brewing have you been following the uh nerfs and the gaussian splatting and all of this tech or basically you could take a couple of pictures of something and get a 3d model i am so intrigued i see i don't go on x x on twitter that much when i do i have some people who have been doing this and it blows my mind i don't i like literally don't understand it at all except i i know how like traditional photogrammetry works in theory, right? Like taking pictures, matching features. Jason and I have talked about this before. We used to do some work in this field prior. So like I understand like matching features from thing to thing, understanding parallax,
产生连锁反应。我觉得人们之前可能受过点挫折，所以还需要一点时间，但我认为一场革命正在酝酿之中。你有关注过NeRFs、高斯泼溅（Gaussian Splatting）以及所有这些技术吗？基本上就是你可以拍几张照片，然后得到一个3D模型。我非常感兴趣。我不怎么上X（Twitter），但当我上去的时候，看到有些人正在做这些，这简直让我大开眼界。我完全理解不了，除了在理论上知道传统的摄影测量法是怎么工作的，对吧？比如拍照、匹配特征。Jason和我之前聊过这个。我们以前在这个领域做过一些工作。所以我理解从一个物体到另一个物体的特征匹配，理解视差，
like estimating pose. So like a traditional pipeline for building that stuff, I understand. When I watch the nerfs and Gaussian splatting, I don't understand. Like I just see the things like thin wires and strings that traditionally would have been impossible to do via you know other mechanisms they just would have screwed up and i see them work and it's just like they blow my mind away but i i haven't done the deep dive to figure out what they're actually doing yeah we should do a show on it um i know a decent amount i know a decent amount about it. But yeah, that's really cool. Yeah, I feel like that's all kind of coming to a head, isn't it?
比如估计姿态。所以对于构建这些东西的传统流程，我是理解的。但当我看到NeRFs和高斯泼溅时，我就看不懂了。我看到那些细线和绳索，按照传统机制是不可能做出来的，它们本来应该会搞砸，但我看到它们成功了，这简直让我惊叹不已。但我还没有深入研究它们到底是怎么运作的。是的，我们应该做一期节目聊聊这个。我对此了解不少。但这真的很酷。是的，我觉得这一切似乎都到了一个临界点，不是吗？
Like, imagine if you break something. It's not completely shattered. It's just broken in two. You could, like, you know, put the two pieces next to each other, you know, get a 3D model out and then 3D print a replacement. Something that'd be freaking awesome see we already but we already passed our prediction thing it has to be like no one do this this year we got a pretty good for 2025 if you do it we have to be advisors on my company or something um all right so rick vegas, what's the, what are the essential things you think every programmer should know? For example, commands, types, for loops, dictionaries, arrays, what are the important things that cross all languages?
比如，想象一下如果你弄坏了什么东西。它没有完全粉碎，只是断成了两截。你可以把这两块拼在一起，生成一个3D模型，然后打印一个替换件。那简直太棒了。看，我们已经过了预测环节了，这必须得是“今年没人能做到”才行。如果我们2025年能做到，那我们得去当顾问或者什么的。好了，Rick Vegas，你认为每个程序员都应该掌握的基本功是什么？比如命令、类型、for循环、字典、数组，哪些是跨语言通用的重要知识？
Machine op codes, you should have memorized assembly set for, for, for, you know, at least three or four different. For RISC-V. Yeah, I mean, it's a good question. I would say, I mean, there's definitely, you know, definitely data structures. Actually, I would say university does a pretty good job of covering the abstractions in a pretty general way. Data structures, they use sorting as a way to teach recursion and also teach algorithms and complexity. A lot of people get turned off when we talk about all the different sorting stuff in in undergrad um they say themselves like why why would i learn this when it's like dot sort in
机器操作码，你应该背下至少三四种汇编指令集。比如RISC-V。是的，这是个好问题。我会说，肯定有数据结构。其实我觉得大学在教授抽象概念方面做得相当不错，非常通用。数据结构，他们用排序来教授递归，同时也教授算法和复杂度。很多人在本科阶段听到各种排序算法时会感到厌烦，他们会问，既然几乎每种语言都有.sort()，为什么还要学这些？
almost every language right um but it's really just a case study in you know different different ways of solving the same problem and how to relate them to each other and everything. So, um, so I would say, you know, you know, it's hard to give that answer, uh, you know, in, in five minutes, but, but I think, I think that, you know, the, the undergrad curriculum is like pretty good at, at giving kind of the overall basics and, you know, you don't, it doesn't mean you have to get an undergrad, but it's a really good, know launch point yeah i you know if i had to like add one thing i agree with you you know a lot of people would say like hash hash map or something which is is definitely also like a good one when you start growing up in size but if i had to add like something to the data structures
但其实这只是解决同一个问题的不同案例研究，以及如何将它们相互关联。所以，很难在五分钟内给出答案，但我认为本科课程在打基础方面做得相当好。这并不意味着你必须拿到本科学位，但它确实是一个很好的起点。是的，如果非要我加一个，我同意你的观点。很多人会说哈希映射（Hash Map）之类的，当你处理的数据量变大时，这绝对很重要。但如果要在数据结构和算法以及那种分解问题的思维方式之外再加一点，我会加字符串操作。
and algorithms and a sort of way of thinking and decomposing things i would add string manipulation um it doesn't have to be like regexes but just like being able to like and maybe it comes from doing programming competition i don't know but like so many times i see just folks struggle like i have a string i don't know how to get the thing i want out of the string and it's just like no be comfortable and sort of like it could be crappy it could be like non-efficient it doesn't matter just know how to like i have a string the string isn't what i want i want some piece of it or some recombination of it and that that requires of course like you know arrays because mostly we treat strings as you know arrays of characters uh you know it requires looping it requires you know arrays
不一定是正则表达式，就是能够处理字符串。也许是因为我参加过编程竞赛，不知道，但我经常看到人们在处理字符串时很挣扎，比如“我有一个字符串，但我不知道怎么从中提取我想要的部分”。其实很简单，不用太纠结，哪怕写得烂一点、效率低一点都没关系，只要知道怎么做就行。我有一个字符串，它不是我想要的，我想要其中的一部分或者重新组合它。这当然需要数组，因为我们通常把字符串当作字符数组来处理，也需要循环，需要数组的数组，并且要对此感到得心应手。
of arrays and being comfortable in that but like just really be comfortable like taking a string chopping it up and getting the pieces you want out of it is uh they don't really teach that in data structure now they teach things you would need for doing it but that specific like additional one just like very very common oh and debugging oh man that's a great one yeah actually that is one thing that's not taught very well in school because it's so language specific um but just getting whichever language you know when you start your first job chances are you probably won't have any control over the language. They'll say, hey, you're writing in C++ or Python or whatever. I thought you were going to name something esoteric.
真的要熟练掌握如何拆解字符串并提取你想要的部分。数据结构课上其实不教这个，他们教的是实现这些功能所需的底层知识，但这种非常实用的技能……哦，还有调试，天哪，这太重要了。是的，这确实是学校里教得不太好的一点，因为它太依赖于具体语言了。但无论你掌握哪种语言，当你开始第一份工作时，很可能你对语言没有选择权。他们会说，嘿，你得用C++或Python写代码。我以为你会说出什么晦涩难懂的语言。
It's your first day on the job and you have to write in, what was it, Plet or something? That one where it's all images. Dude, that's awesome. Wasn debugger works in that language and and how to profile and find out what how where your code is fast and slow is really important oh i wasn't thinking that would be but yes you mentioned that was good performance analysis as well. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. Yeah, both. All the things you need to know.
上班第一天，你得用什么来写代码？Plet还是什么？就是那种全是图像的语言。伙计，那太酷了。调试器在那种语言里是怎么工作的，以及如何进行性能分析，找出代码哪里快哪里慢，这非常重要。哦，我没想到你会提到这个，但你说得对，性能分析也很重要。是的，两者都很重要。所有你需要知道的事情。
Yeah. Debugging and perf analysis. Super, super important. Um, all right. So Hoover, Hoover shoes, hover shoes, uh, asks, Oh, this is going to be a tough one. Um, I'm a computer science student who's still deciding how I want to organize my life. Like, for example, what purpose? And he gave some examples, raise a family, effective altruism, doing cool engineering and science.
是的。调试和性能分析。超级、超级重要。好了，Hoover Shoes问了一个问题，哦，这会是个难题。我是一名计算机科学专业的学生，还在决定如何规划我的人生。比如，人生目标是什么？他举了一些例子，比如组建家庭、有效利他主义、从事酷炫的工程和科学研究。
What purpose his career should serve? Question is, were there profound experiences you had that made you want to pursue a particular life? And I think he means outside of work or, you know, a life that your career affords you. So, yeah, I think. Man, I have to think about this for a minute. I don't know if you have a quicker answer, Patrick. So for me, that's definitely like a part of it. But just in general, I would say, you know, leaving that aside that you kind of have to pick, in my opinion, and decide what is work going to define like who you are, or are you going to have like a definition of who you are? And like you work to kind of achieve it, I guess, like hand wave without getting into, you know, having thought to write it. And I think that both kinds are okay. And, and I'll give an example, which is I routinely have career conversations with people, you know, I've talked to people over the years, managers, there are some people who will say, I never want to work on an ad system ads are, you know, are bad. And I don't want to work on, you know, anything that has to do with serving ads,
他的职业生涯应该服务于什么目的？问题是，你们是否有过什么深刻的经历，让你们想要追求某种特定的人生？我觉得他指的是工作之外，或者说职业生涯所能支撑的生活。所以，是的，我得想一想。Patrick，你有没有更快的答案？对我来说，这绝对是其中的一部分。但总的来说，我认为，撇开这些不谈，你必须做出选择，决定工作是定义你本身，还是你拥有自己对自己的定义，而工作只是为了实现它。我不深入探讨细节，但我认为两种方式都可以。我举个例子，我经常和人们进行职业对话，多年来我谈过很多人，经理们，有些人会说，我永远不想从事广告系统的工作，广告是坏的。我不想从事任何与投放广告、构建广告相关的工作，
building ads, building ads, like, you know, just, and you can insert any, you know, are bad. And I don't want to work on, you know, anything that has to do with serving ads, building ads, building ads, like, you know, just, and you can insert any, you know, topic here. Other people might say, you know, I don't have a specific moral, like, you know, problem with ads. So as long as if the technology I'm working on, and I'm learning something, and I'm engaged, and I have a good team, you know, these things are more important. I think this is a slice of that same problem, which is, do you go to work and, you know, you spend a lot of time with the people there and on those topics. So it is perfectly fine to want those to align very closely with your internal beliefs. But I think it is also okay to say you have a very strong, you know, external, so you might call that work-life balance, you might call it whatever, but you have very strong external, you have a family, you know, several people you might call that work-life balance you might call it whatever but you have very strong external you have a family you know whether that's your own
你可以把任何话题代入进去。其他人可能会说，我对广告没有特定的道德问题。只要我从事的技术能让我学到东西，我感到投入，并且有一个好的团队，这些事情更重要。我认为这只是同一个问题的不同侧面，即你去工作，花很多时间和那里的人讨论那些话题。所以，希望这些与你的内在信念高度一致是完全没问题的。但我认为，拥有非常强大的外部生活也是可以的，你可以称之为工作与生活的平衡，或者其他什么，但你有非常强大的外部生活，你有家庭，无论那是你的配偶和孩子，还是你的父母或兄弟姐妹，这都不重要，或者你的朋友圈，你专注于工作之外的爱好，而工作只是为了赚钱，提供好的保险，支撑你的生活。我认为这两种方式都没问题。要理解人们会在两者之间调节，而且我再说一遍，我不认为这是静态的。随着时间的推移，人们会来回调节这个旋钮。所以我不知道有什么建议可以给你，我认为这是一个你应该自己做的决定，并且要深思熟虑，你工作的理由是什么，你为什么工作，
you know spouse and children or whether it's your parents or your brothers like it doesn't matter or friend group and you're really you know focused a hobby outside of work and work as a way to like make money and like you know provide good insurance and support your life i think both are okay and being understanding that there are people who turn that dial between those two and again already the hobby horse i don't think it's static over time i think various times people can have that knob turn back and forth so i don't know that there's advice you can give you i think it's a decision you should make um and be thoughtful about like what what is the reason that you work and why do you work and
你为什么在现在的地方工作，你应该不时地重新评估。也许你会意识到应该做出改变。对于某些人来说，如果你总是让工作定义自己，这会成为一个绊脚石，因为换工作会变得非常困难，就像是在改变身份。我只想说，至少在西方社会，在我们当前的资本主义环境下，无论你怎么看，让工作拥有那种控制权，并不能引导你走向博弈论的最优解。如果你让工作对你拥有那种控制权，你最终可能会被低估、被亏待。也许如果你去创业，自己当创始人，那另当别论。
why do you work where you work and you should reevaluate it from time to time and and maybe come to the realization that it should switch and for some people i will say it becomes a bit of a stumbling block if you allow it always to be turned to work defines me then it becomes very difficult to switch jobs because you're almost switching identities and i will just say in i guess i'll say at least in western society in our current you know capitalistic whatever you think about that allowing work to have that control over you is something that doesn't lead you to a game theoretic optimum right like you are going to end up being probably underpaid under thing, if you allow work to have a sort of hold over you that you have to do that. Maybe if you go run a startup and your
我对此不予置评，我从未做过。但这可能是一条出路。但除此之外，如果你在一家中型或大型公司工作，这在那个旋钮上停留太久是一个危险的位置，即“我允许这份工作定义我是谁”。所以这是我唯一的警示。但除此之外，我认为这是每个人都会面临的问题，你会在一个团队中工作，团队里的每个人对这个问题的定义都不同。是的，非常棒的回答。和Patrick类似，对我来说，我有很多工作之外的事情，比如教会服务和其他一些事情，当我回首往事时，它们是我生命中很重要的一部分。我看到过一句话，我是一个看电影会哭的人，我承认这一点。当音乐以某种方式响起时，他们确实找到了某种窍门。
own founder, and that that is, I'll leave that aside. I don't, I can't sort of speak to that. I've never done it. But that may be a way out. But otherwise, if you're working at sort of like a medium or big company, and you know, that's a dangerous place in the dial to be for too long, which is I allow this work to be who I am. So that would be my only caution there. But otherwise, I think it's something that individuals all will and you will work on a team where everyone on that team defines that differently. Yeah, fantastic answer. I mean, similar to Patrick, I think for me, you know, I have a lot of things outside of work, things related to kind of church service and some of these other things that that, you know, when I look back on are a big part of my life i think um man i saw this thing that like i don't really get to i am the kind of person that cries in movies i'm guilty of that you know there's something about like when the music plays a certain way like they've they've like figured out um and you know i realized at some point i i
有一次我中途走进电影院，开始变得非常感性。我意识到，我甚至不知道电影在演什么。只是当音乐响起，人们的神态和摄像机的角度以某种方式呈现时，它就触发了我内心深处的某种东西。
came into a movie about halfway through and I started getting real emotional. And I realized like, I don't even know what's going on in this movie. It's just when they have the music a certain way and the people look a certain way and the angles, a certain way, the camera, like it just triggers something in me.
所以我在这方面是个感性的人，但我对在网上看到的东西、名言之类的并没有那种感觉。但我发现了这一句名言，它说，
So I'm kind of a sap in that way, but, but I saw, but I don't really feel that way about, you know, you know, things I see on the internet or quotes or anything like that. But I found this one quote and it said,
它说的是，有一个更年轻的你，会为你现在的样子感到无比自豪。这真的触动了我。就像，伙计，你真的会忘记多年前的自己，以及整个旅程。所以，对我来说，我尽量保持一种——我想用“纯粹”这个词，虽然不太准确，但我想要保持一种不被妥协的状态。
it said something like there's a younger version of you who would be like so proud of, you know, like who you are right now. Right. And that like really hit me. It's like, man, you kind of forget about what you were like, you know, like so many years ago and, and, and the whole journey. Right. So I think, um, for me, I try to stay like pretty, I can't, I want to use the word pure. It's not really the right word, but like, I want to keep like pretty, like, uh, not like compromised, you know, like if, um, um, I want to have like, it doesn't mean that like, I just have no filter and I just tell everyone like, oh, you know, you're fat or something like that. No, it's not it.
这并不意味着我没有过滤，见人就说“哦，你很胖”之类的。不，不是那样。
But it's like, but it's like, you know, in my head I have kind of like an unadulterated view of like myself and the, you know, my place i'm in and the world around me and everything and so i can kind of uh make predictions that come true at least you know locally i'm not predicting like you know anything like the lottery or anything but but yeah but like locally in my life i can kind of like make predictions that that more or less come true because i have like a pretty clear view of what's going on um i think that that's something that um that i think is really important and you know if you have that then you can kind of say like where do i want to be and like you know what is the path that i could take to get there and just you, doing that kind of one step at a time. Um, um, and so I think as Patrick said, there's times where, you know, I'm really passionate about some work thing. And so, you know, life is kind of getting in the way of solving this
而是说，在我的脑海里，我对自我、我所处的位置以及周围的世界有一种清晰的认知，所以我可以做出一些能实现的预测。至少在局部范围内，我不是在预测彩票之类的。但在我个人的生活中，我可以做出一些或多或少会实现的预测，因为我对正在发生的事情有相当清晰的认识。我认为这非常重要。如果你有了这一点，你就可以说，我想去哪里，我可以通过什么路径到达那里，然后一步一个脚印地去做。
problem or getting some, some work thing done. And there are other times where I really have a lot going on outside of work and work is really there to pay the bills or to be something that I do during the day before I do the thing I really want to do. And so you're constantly going to keep moving through that space. I don't think that you'll ever be just focused on on one or the other um but yeah i do think it's important to really take inventory of of yourself you could look back really far like as that as that slogan was suggesting or you could even look back in the past week and say you know what did i do this week um you know did i kind of end this week kind of better than i started it um did i waste a lot of time this week and do i have a whole bunch of regrets is there things i can fix there or am i overall pretty pretty happy i think there are
正如Patrick所说，有时候我真的对某项工作充满热情，所以生活反而成了解决问题或完成工作的阻碍。而其他时候，我工作之外的事情很多，工作只是为了付账单，或者只是我在做真正想做的事情之前白天要做的事。所以你会不断地在这些状态之间切换。我不认为你会永远只专注于其中一个。但我确实认为，定期审视自己非常重要。你可以像那句口号建议的那样回首很久以前，或者你甚至可以回顾过去的一周，问问自己这周做了什么，这周结束时是否比开始时更好，这周是否浪费了很多时间，是否有遗憾，有什么可以弥补的，或者总体上是否感到快乐。
like uh so many people that you know on on social media and other places that are trying to tell you how to be happy or, you know, give you purpose in your life. And, uh, I don't know, I'm a little skeptical. I haven't listened to any of them and I look back and I feel like it was probably a good decision. Yeah. I mean, you made some good points there. I think like for me, I guess like if I iterate on what you're saying too, is I think people get a little hung up about setting specific goalposts that they want to like, it's like very, very, like if you think about all the design space
社交媒体和其他地方有太多人试图告诉你如何获得幸福，或者给你的人生赋予意义。我对此持怀疑态度。我没听过他们的任何建议，回首往事，我觉得这可能是一个正确的决定。是的，你提到了几个很好的点。对我来说，如果我重复你的观点，我认为人们在设定具体目标时会陷入困境。如果你考虑所有可能的发展空间，家庭、婚姻等等，他们设定了非常具体的目标。比如我必须结婚，我想要在几岁之前结婚。人们设定了非常具体的目标，工作方面也是如此。对我来说，
of everywhere you can be, family, marriage, whatever, they set very specific goals. Like I have to be married and I want to be married by this age. And I want, like people set very specific things and work related as well. For me, it's about like,
正如你所暗示的，Jason，每一天、每一月、每一年，我都在尝试实现复合增长。基于我目前的能力，诚实地面对自己，如果我想成长，不仅仅是吃补品或参加课程，而是我需要每周多花一点时间，不要试图进行阶梯式的突变，而是缓慢地调整我的人生航向，并意识到越远的事情，不确定性就越大。我今天想要的五年后的我，与我五年后最终成为的样子很可能非常不同。
and I think you're sort of alluding to that, Jason, is like each day, each month, each year year like trying to just have that compounding growth so for where i am right now given the extents of my abilities like being honest about that and saying if i want to grow it's not just like go take a supplement or go you know take a course it's like i need to start spending a little bit more time each week, and not trying to have these like step function changes, but just slowly move the, you know, heading of my vector through the space, and realize that further away, you know, items are going to have a bigger cone of uncertainty. And what I want today, for me in five years, is very different than what I will probably end up
但我希望回首往事时，能说“我很高兴我曾处于那个位置”，并意识到你的处境以及什么是你能控制的，什么不是。但我个人从未对“你必须有一个五年计划并为之奋斗”这种说法产生共鸣。也许对某些人来说，这确实是严格必要的。但我发现对我自己而言，我从未有过什么目标，除了比今天的自己稍微好一点。在五年内成长，而不必非要完成某个愿望清单，否则就觉得自己失败了。回首往事，有一件事我觉得是相当普遍的，我对此感到非常高兴，那就是我没有恐惧或羞耻感。
being in five years. But I want to look back like that, like look back and say, Oh, I'm still happy that like, like, this is a good spot to have been in, and be realizing your circumstances and what is and isn't in your control. But personally, I've never resonated with this, like, you have to have a five year goal and be pushing with it, or where are you going to end up? Maybe, maybe it's a maybe for some people, that is actually a strict necessity. But I found for myself, it's like, I've never really had a like goal other than to be somewhat better than I am today. Like being more and having grown and across like all the things in five years without specifically, like I need to have done this bucket list or checklist in five years, or I will, I will be sort of like have missed my goal. i mean looking back one thing that i feel is pretty universal that i'm really
我会去尝试，这个节目就是一个很好的例子。每一期我们都在谈论一种编程语言，剧透一下，Patrick和我并不是Unity之类的专家。偶尔我们会收到真正专家的邮件，告诉我们我们根本不懂自己在说什么，这没关系。在众多积极的邮件中，这只是一封邮件，所以它根本不会困扰我。但我们确实会收到这样的反馈，我想那个人可能是对的。但Patrick和我还是尽可能多地去谈论各种编程语言。
kind of happy with is that i didn't i didn't really have any um like uh like fear or shame you know like uh um um yeah i'll put myself out there I'll try like the show is a great example. Like every, every episode we talk about a programming language of spoiler alert, Patrick and I are not experts on like unity, right? Like every now and then we'll get an email from someone who's really an expert on a language telling us how, like, we don't know what we're talking about and that's fine. I mean, it's, it's one email in the span of many many many positive emails so it doesn't bother me at all but but i mean we do get that and i think that person's probably right um but you know patrick and i kind of put ourselves out there to talk about as many programming languages as possible
我们尽力去谈论这些语言，尽可能好地向大家解释。我们并没有因为不是每种语言的专家而退缩。我认为这种精神渗透到了所有事情中。我在大学时就有这样一个哲学，我会和任何一个我可能在课堂上相处得来的人约会。
and you know we can um um you know we can do our best to talk about the language, to explain it to folks as best we can. And we're not really deterred by the fact that we're not experts in every language. And so I think that kind of, I think, percolates through everything. I had this philosophy, like this is so many years ago in college, I would always go on a date on one date with anybody, any, any, any girl who, uh, who, um, um, you know, if we seem like we were, we got along maybe in a class or something, I'd always like try
如果我提出约会，或者如果有人邀请我，我都会去。当你持有这种哲学时，你会被拒绝很多次，人们可能有男朋友，或者只是对你不感兴趣，等等。但我认为所有这些经历都非常有用。最终，我和一个女孩约会，我们结婚了，我今天为能和她结婚感到非常自豪。所以，不要害怕。不要害怕进行社交活动。真正地推动自己。你可以从中吸取教训。我确实有一些遗憾，比如在工作中发生的争吵，或者因为一些其实没那么重要的事情而大发雷霆。
and ask to on a date or if a girl asked me to go on a date i'd go on one date with anybody and and uh and and so when you have that philosophy you get rejected all the time people have boyfriends or they are just not into you or whatever and um um but i think all of those experiences were really useful and eventually you know i went on a date with a girl who then we got married and I'm really proud to be married to her today. So without a parachute, yeah, be afraid. But don't be afraid to do social things. Really kind of push yourself. And you can learn lessons from that. There are definitely things I regret, arguments I got into at work, times where I raised a big stink out of something about something that
每个人都有这些……它们不是秘密，因为大家都知道，但怎么说呢，那些让你感到遗憾、压在心头的事情。但这也需要放在你所做的一切、所说的一切的背景下，那些对人们产生巨大积极影响的事情。所以，我能告诉大家最重要的事情就是去冒险、去探索，尽可能多地了解自己、了解周围的人，以及了解编程语言。这聊得太深了。好了，下一个问题来自Champion Two-Timer。
really wasn't that big a deal you know everyone has these kind of uh they're not skeletons because everyone knows about it but but what's the word but things that you regret that kind of weigh on you right um but uh um but that you know there, that also needs to be in the context of like all the things you did, all the things you said, uh, that, that had a huge impact, a positive impact on people. So, um, so yeah, just, just, uh, I think the biggest, the biggest, um, um, the biggest thing that I could try and tell people is to just take chances and explore and uh um you know and learn as much as you can about yourself about people around you and about programming languages that got really deep all right uh so next question from champion two-timer
哦，Two-Timer Champion，这很酷。我刚才说出名字时才反应过来。现在我们想知道他们是哪方面的冠军。你应该告诉我们，Champion，如果你现在在Discord里的话。其实我要问问Champion他是什么方面的冠军。但与此同时，你们在大学时是什么样的程序员？你们毕业后的第一份工作是什么？Patrick和我做的是同一份工作，所以这会很有趣。Patrick，你先来。我是一个糟糕的程序员。不，在大学里，我只是用它来尝试很多不同的东西。所以我不知道该怎么回答我当时是什么样的程序员。
oh two-timer champion that's cool okay i just figured it out as i said the name and now we want to know what their champions of yeah you should tell us champion if you're in the discord right now um um actually i'm gonna ask champion tell us what he's a champion of but in the meantime uh what kind of programmers were you in college and what was your first job when you got out patrick and i had the same job so this is gonna be interesting patrick why don't you go first i was a terrible programmer no and i'm just in college i mean i used it to like try a lot of different things so i guess like i don't i don't exactly know how to answer what kind of programmer i was uh
在大学里，但我毕业时确实不确定自己要做什么。我第一份工作是在一家国防承包商。但我参加了一个项目，在工作的头几年里，我可以尝试各种不同的项目。这对我很有吸引力。而且我还可以同时攻读硕士学位。所以对我来说，大学毕业意味着继续深造，同时也意味着尝试各种不同的东西。我觉得这对我很有回报。我一直秉持的哲学是，职业生涯早期，你应该尽可能多地尝试，
in in college but uh i definitely wasn't like super sure what I was going to do when I got out. I first job I took was at a defense contractor. But I did it as part of a program where I would get to try a bunch of different projects there over the first few years that I was going to work there. And so that really appealed to me. And also I was going to get my master's degree at the same time. So for me, coming out of college was like about continuing my education, but also about getting to try a bunch of different things. Cause I feel like it paid off for me, but I, I've always been in the philosophy, like the earlier you in your career, you really want to like, for, for my personality, it was like really sample as many things as you
变得擅长各种事情。但在某个阶段，就像金字塔一样，你需要打好基础。随着你的成长，你想要缩小关注范围，直到你在某些方面变得越来越精通。但前提是你已经建立了一个良好的基础。所以，是的，大学毕业后的第一份工作是在国防承包商。我很享受那段时光。我学到了很多。我还没准备好直接去……我之前提到过，我在几家大厂工作过，但我毕业时还没准备好去那些地方。我需要成熟一点，成长一点，然后再进入那种环境。所以我很感激那份工作，但后来它不再适合我了，我很庆幸自己能够转岗。是的，我当时在大学里非常有竞争力，我甚至赢得了高中的编程竞赛。
can, like become good in things. Uh, at some point though, it's like a, you know, pyramid, you want to have like a good foundation. But as you like go up, you want to like narrow in your focus until you become better and better and better at certain things. But that you have like a good foundation that you've built up on. So yeah, I guess coming out of college first was at a defense contractor. I enjoyed my time there. I learned a lot. I wasn't ready to go straight into I mentioned earlier, I've been at a couple of thing companies, but lot. I wasn't ready to go straight into, I mentioned earlier, been at a couple of FANG companies, but I wasn't ready for that right out of college. I needed to mature a little, grow a little before getting sort of thrown into that. So I appreciated that first job, but there was a time when it was no longer the right job for me. And so I was thankful that I was able to rotate out of that. Yeah. In you know i was really really uh competitive in the i actually
正因为如此，我做了很多底层编程，因为大多数竞赛都使用C++。你可以用Java，但有些情况下Java不够快，所以如果用C++，你的答案就是正确的。我有一段时间在竞赛方面使用Java，后来又换回了C++。这给了我一种非常底层的思维方式。关于CSV文件不使用数据库的笑话，在我刚开始工作时，这离事实并不远。所以我在大学里就是这样，任何问题都直接用C++解决，没有第三方库，什么都没有。
won the high school programming contest in my high school um and so because of that i ended up doing a lot of low level programming just because um most of these competitions you use c++ um you could use java but there were some things where java was not fast enough and so your answer would be correct if it was in c++ and so i had a brief period on the competitive side where i was where I was using Java and I switched back to C++ and so that that gave me like a very uh um um like like a like a very low level mindset where um you know the joke about the CSV file and not using a database I mean that's not far from the truth when when I was uh just starting and uh um and so that's kind of how i was in college it's just like you know any problem let's just throw c++ at it not no uh no third-party libraries no nothing
只用C++写一切。我和Patrick做的是同一份工作，我们就是在那儿认识的。我觉得有趣的一点是，那只是当地的一份工作。我觉得很多人可能会觉得第一份工作真的定义了他们是谁。其实，我第一份技术工作是在大学期间做的，我为佛罗里达州政府做兼职，做一些技术工作。但我认为不必太纠结于第一份工作。无论你接触到什么，都会是一次很棒的经历。我们在那儿工作了很久。Patrick，你在那儿待了多久？我待了大约五年。
just write everything in c++ um um i went to the same job as patrick that's how we met was at our first job um and uh i guess the thing that makes that kind of uh interesting is is um you know it was uh just a job in the area i think that so many people might feel like their first job you know really defines who they are i mean actually my I mean, actually, my first tech job I had while I was still in college, I worked part-time for the state of Florida doing some tech stuff for them. But yeah, I think I wouldn't really stress too much about your first job. I think whatever you get your hands on is going to be a great experience. And we were there. Patrick, how long were you at our first job? I was there about five years.
我想我正好待了五年。是的，我想是差一点到五年。大概四年多一点。是的，据说满五年会发个钟之类的，但我走得太快了。是的，我知道。我确实到了第五年，但我走得太快了，没拿到钟。但那是非常棒的五年。从我的角度来看，对于Patrick可能有点不同，我当时就像是闭着眼睛投飞镖。我只是了解那家公司，面试，然后就在那儿工作了五年。
I think I was there exactly five years. Yeah, I think it was just shy of five. I think it was like four and some change. Yeah, apparently at five you got, I think think a clock or something, but I left too quickly. Yeah, I know. I literally hit the fifth year, but I think I left so quickly after that, I didn't get my clock. But, you know, it was five amazing years. And, you know, it was basically for my point of view, for Patrick, it might be a little different. My point, for my point of view is basically just throwing a dart at a dartboard. I just knew about this company interviewed, uh, and then just worked there
那段经历非常有回报。所以如果随机抽签都能抽到一份这么有回报的工作，那么我的结论就是，第一份工作是什么真的不重要。你都会学到很多。是的，我在这里打住，剩下的问题我们可能得进入快问快答环节了。另外，我不认为Jason——不是冒犯他或我自己——我们都不是来自那种大厂的目标院校。他们不去那里招聘，我们也不是来自那种传统意义上大家都会去大厂的学校。所以我说同样的话，人们总是非常担心自己上哪所大学，第一份工作是什么。
for five years and, and it was extremely rewarding. And so if, if just a random draw gave a really rewarding job like that, then the takeaway for me is that it really doesn't matter what your first job is. You're going to, you're going to learn a lot. Yeah. I mean, I'll drop right here and then we'll probably have to go into lightning round for the rest of these questions but uh also i don't think jason not no offense to him or myself but neither of us came from sort of target schools for big tech companies so like right that they don't recruit there but like we didn't come from schools that you know traditionally you see as people going there and so i'll say the same thing people get really really like worried about exactly what college they go to exactly what first job they have you know traditionally you see as people going there and so i'll say the same thing people get
我觉得这只是关于建立你的品格、技能和能力。这可能需要时间，根据某些决定，过程可能会更难或更容易。但就像Jason说的，我认为这在很大程度上是一个相当稳健的过程。所以，再次强调，要对自己所处的位置和想要达到的位置有现实的认知，你需要成长吗？有些人会有过高的期望。
really really like worried about exactly what college they go to exactly what first job they have i think it's just about building up your character and your your skills and your abilities and you know it might take time and it can be harder or easier based on certain decisions but like i guess like jason said it's i think it's a fairly robust kind of thing for the most part, you know? And so, but again, it's, it's about being that like realistic about where you are and where you want to be and do you need to grow? And so some, some people have a sort of outsized view.
你要谦虚，但要务实。不要在任何一方面走极端。不要低估你的技能，也不要高估它们。你必须对自己的现状和目标有现实的认知。是的，完全同意。那么我们来发最后一件T恤。最后一件T恤将送给一位名叫Arieb K的先生，希望我没念错你的名字。
You got to be humble, but practical. Like don't, don't, don't err too far on either side. Don't underestimate your skills and don't overestimate them either. You have to be realistic about where you are and where you want to be. Yeah, totally. So we'll do the final shirt. The final shirt is going to a gentleman named, and I hope I don't butcher your names, Arieb. Arieb K.
Arieb已经支持我们四年了。非常感谢你，Arieb，感谢你的赞助。我们会把T恤寄给你。好了，我来读下一个问题，Jason。好的。问题是，很多人已经专业化了。哦，我想我已经回答过这个问题了。糟糕。
Arieb has been a patron for four years. Thank you so much, Arieb, for your patronage. And we will get a t-shirt over to you. All right, I'll read the next question here, Jason. All right. Which is, a lot of people already specialize. Oh, I think I already answered this. Uh-oh.
人们已经专业化了，至少知道他们想走什么路径，无论是AI、安全、DevOps、数据工程还是Web开发。我是一名职业生涯早期的后端软件工程师，我几乎什么都能接触一点。这就是我喜欢它的原因。但从职业角度来看，我应该更多地考虑专业化吗？专业化是真实存在的吗？还是仅仅是一个头衔？这是Cup of Geo问的。是的，这是一个很好的问题。我认为你应该……在工程的背景下，你应该做你喜欢的事情，做那些能给你带来最大力量的事情。所以，再次强调，在你的工作背景下，如果你在工作中确实发现自己做了很多不同的事情，希望你是在一个团队中，也许你可以进行一些交换，说：“嘿，我来做这部分工作。”
People already specialize, at least knowing what path they want to be on, whether it's AI, security, DevOps, data engineering, web dev. I'm an early career backend software engineer, and I get to play a little bit with almost everything. And that's what I like about it. But from a career perspective, should I be thinking more about specializing? Is specialize even real? Or is it just like a title? This is from cup of geo yeah that's a great question i think that i think you should um you know within the context of of engineering you should do what you uh what you enjoy you know what what gives you the most strength so uh you know again within the context of your job so um so if at your job you know you do find yourself doing a lot of different things, you're hopefully on a team and, you know, maybe you can do some horse trading and say, hey, I'll do the, you know, this part of the work.
人们已经开始专业化了，至少知道他们想走什么路径，无论是人工智能、安全、DevOps、数据工程还是Web开发。我是一名职业生涯早期的后端软件工程师，我几乎可以接触到所有东西。这就是我喜欢它的地方。但从职业角度来看，我应该更多地考虑专业化吗？专业化是真实存在的吗？还是仅仅是一个头衔？这是来自cup of geo的问题，是的，这是一个很好的问题，我认为，我认为你应该，嗯，你知道，在工程的背景下，你应该做你，嗯，你喜欢的事情，你知道，什么能给你最大的力量，所以，嗯，你知道，再次强调，在你的工作背景下，所以，嗯，所以如果你的工作中，你知道，你发现自己做了很多不同的事情，希望你是在一个团队中，而且，你知道，也许你可以做一些交换，说，嘿，我会做，你知道，这部分工作。
You know, I'll do the refactoring if you take this other item or what have you. And you can kind of find the thing that you really enjoy and double down on that um um and so you know in that sense like it's going to kind of guide you to be more and more specialized over time um but at the same time like uh um you know you have to kind of keep your eye on the kind of overall market and kind of where the puck is going. Um, so, you know, I think, uh, if like, if you're at a company that uses, um, um, what's it called? Like ASP.net or something, right. Which like every year, you know, loses market share. Well then, you know, take a little bit of time to learn um to learn uh you know node.js or something just so that so that you you you're kind of skating to where the puck is going
你知道，如果你接手这个任务，我就去做重构，或者诸如此类的事情。你可以找到自己真正喜欢的东西并深耕下去。从这个意义上说，它会引导你随着时间的推移变得越来越专业。但与此同时，你必须关注整体市场，关注行业的发展趋势。所以，如果你所在的公司使用的是，呃，叫什么来着？比如 ASP.net 之类的，而它的市场份额每年都在流失，那么花点时间去学习 Node.js 之类的东西，这样你就能顺应行业的发展趋势。
there um even if you're not using it at work so so you know it's a balance to strike i would say really it depends on what gives you kind of strength and energy as a as an engineer and different people have different things some get bored really easily if they start specializing um other people um you end up in the sort of analysis paralysis when they have too many options and they really just need to pick something and start start specializing so it's a very personal question, but I think the biggest thing is just monitor yourself and adjust accordingly. Yeah, I think for a slightly different tech, but I already kind of mentioned it. I actually don't think it's super important to worry about what you want to be when you grow up.
即使你在工作中不用它。所以这是一种平衡。我认为这真的取决于什么能给你作为工程师带来力量和动力。不同的人有不同的偏好，有些人如果开始专业化就会很容易感到厌倦；而另一些人，当他们有太多选择时，会陷入分析瘫痪，他们真的只需要选定一个方向并开始专业化。所以这是一个非常个人化的问题，但我认为最重要的是自我监控并做出相应的调整。是的，虽然技术略有不同，但我之前已经提到了。其实我并不认为担心自己长大后想成为什么样的人是非常重要的。
I was having this conversation with my kids and I don't really know what I want to be when I grow up. I mean, my current specialty as a software engineer is like, or I guess what I've been working on the last many years, it's completely something I didn't really necessarily knew existed. It's not something I would have been working on. It's, uh, you know, in a field supporting things that I didn't like probably weren't even an option when I was in college. And so I think that like, it's very hard to predict some of those things and i started out doing you know we talked about a defense contract doing like low level
我和孩子们谈过这个问题，我真的不知道自己长大后想成为什么样的人。我的意思是，我作为软件工程师目前的专长，或者说我过去几年一直在做的工作，完全是我以前不知道存在的东西。这不是我本来会从事的工作。它处于一个支持性的领域，在我上大学时可能甚至都不是一个选项。所以我认为，预测这些事情是非常困难的。我刚开始做的是我们提到的国防合同，做的是底层
embedded programming doing multi-year government maintenance contracts like really weird stuff and then i you know went to fang company and did you know giant large scale distributed map reduced projects and uh you know i've done everything in between and i've sort of taken the tack that like i want to always be learning new things and figuring out how stuff works and there are i i think places in the space that you can learn stuff that's just too niche or like it's uh sort of the expected value of that sort of niche skill is is is low so it may have really high payout but very low probability of that payout um and you can you can gamble on those things if you look back you know uh there are things i i don't want to i don't want to attack
嵌入式编程，做多年期的政府维护合同，非常奇怪的事情。后来我去了大厂，做了超大规模的分布式 MapReduce 项目。我做过各种各样的中间工作，我采取的策略是，我希望不断学习新事物，弄清楚事物是如何运作的。我认为在这个领域里，有些地方你可以学到一些太小众的东西，或者说这种小众技能的预期价值很低，所以它可能有很高的回报，但获得这种回报的概率非常低。你可以去赌这些事情。如果你回顾过去，有些事情我不想去攻击
anyone there are technologies we've even named so far which could be considered like big gambles with potentially big payouts um But they're just that. And you may like that. That may be exciting. Or you may say, which has kind of been more my tech, is take things which are interesting to me, but are somewhat stable or adjacent or skills that will sort of go along with me. And that has served me well.
任何人，我们目前提到的技术中，有些可能被认为是高风险、高回报的赌博。但它们就是这样。你可能喜欢那样，那可能很令人兴奋。或者你可能会说，这更符合我的策略，即选择那些我感兴趣，但相对稳定或相关，或者能伴随我发展的技能。这对我很有帮助。
So I feel that there's a lot of, can be a lot of peer pressure. And a lot of people just know or think that they know, and they might be wrong. But a lot of people who think that they know, and just don't feel that pressure. Like do stuff that you like. And for me, it's about, and Jason kind of mentioned those things about regrets. Don't, I try to look at the upside.
所以我感到有很多同辈压力。很多人自以为知道，或者认为自己知道，但他们可能是错的。但很多自以为知道的人，并没有感受到那种压力。做你喜欢做的事。对我来说，关于遗憾，Jason 提到过那些事情。不要，我试着看好的一面。
There's always been something to learn from all the things I've done. Some stuff has been truly terrible and maybe less learned. Um, but I'm still thankful that I did those things and make sure that I know how to like not do them again, or how could I maybe have avoided that? Right. There's always sort of lessons to be learned. So, uh, I mean, I think first 10 years, I think you don't really have to pick a specialist. I don't know you ever do, but I would also say there is a danger and sort of on a given project, like,
我所做的一切事情中总能学到一些东西。有些事情确实很糟糕，学到的东西可能少一些。但我仍然很感激我做了那些事情，并确保我知道如何避免重蹈覆辙，或者我当时本可以如何避免这种情况？对吧。总是有经验教训可以吸取。所以，我的意思是，我认为前 10 年，你真的不需要选择成为专家。我不知道你是否真的需要，但我还要说，在某个特定项目上，存在一种危险，比如
you know, saying that I just will do anything. I don't want to do any one thing. And you know, every job I take must be different and sort of being a Renaissance person, uh, can be a little dangerous as you want to get promoted further and further. So I think there's about,
你知道，说我什么都愿意做。我不想只做一件事。而且你知道，我接的每一份工作都必须不同，这种成为“文艺复兴式”全才的想法，在你想要进一步晋升时可能会有点危险。所以我认为大约有
you know, it, there's different ways of playing that game and sort of having enough attention spans that you really learn something but then realizing that you can have that time slicing over time is probably better and more stable than sort of going into a project and saying i want to do a little bit of everything here um and sort of forcing yourself to be super spread thin uh doesn't allow you to learn in depth any one thing. And so I would say learn things deeply sequentially, rather than, you know,
你知道，玩转这个游戏有不同的方式，保持足够的注意力去真正学到东西，但意识到随着时间的推移进行时间切片可能比进入一个项目并说“我想在这里做一点点所有事情”更好、更稳定。强迫自己分散精力，无法让你深入学习任何一件事。所以我建议按顺序深入学习，而不是
spread yourself too thin. Yep, that makes sense. All right, we were up to our final question. Thank you so much for the questions. Really interesting stuff. We're going to end on a really light note here do you guys have a favorite this is from sky to see do you guys have a favorite esoteric language um i mentioned it a little bit earlier although i think i got the name wrong but piet which is the one where it's a picture the source code is is literally a picture and the compiler reads that picture and turns it into some algorithm i just think that's really cool. I could imagine some kind of like, it'd be cool to get a PIT program
让自己分散精力。是的，这很有道理。好了，我们到了最后一个问题。非常感谢大家的提问。非常有趣的内容。我们以一个轻松的话题结束，你们有最喜欢的深奥语言吗？这是 Sky 提出的。你们有最喜欢的深奥语言吗？我之前稍微提了一下，虽然我觉得名字记错了，是 Piet，就是那种源代码实际上是一张图片，编译器读取那张图片并将其转化为某种算法的语言。我觉得这真的很酷。我可以想象，如果能有一个 Piet 程序
that sorts into a canvas and put it up in my house somewhere. That'd be pretty neat. Maybe I'll work on that for 2024. But yeah, I just thought that crossing media there I crossing media there, I think, is really interesting. Maybe we can have ChatGPT create a Piat program for me or something. I was going to go Egyptian hieroglyphics before I realized that it meant a programming language, not a...
能整理成一幅画布，挂在我家里的某个地方，那会很棒。也许我会在 2024 年尝试一下。但确实，我认为跨媒介创作非常有趣。也许我们可以让 ChatGPT 为我创建一个 Piet 程序之类的。我本来想说埃及象形文字，后来才意识到那是指一种编程语言，而不是……
I don't really, you know, we joke a lot about, but I've never really sat down and tried to program in many esoteric languages, probably some assembly language. You know, it's interesting the difference between CISC and RISC architectures and assembly. So I did some programming in Motorola 68K assembly, which is CISC. So complex instruction sets. And I actually kind of like that. I guess I don't know if that's considered esoteric. I might offend some people by saying it.
我真的没有，你知道，我们经常开玩笑，但我从来没有真正坐下来尝试用很多深奥的语言编程，可能除了汇编语言。你知道，CISC 和 RISC 架构在汇编语言上的区别很有趣。所以我做过一些 Motorola 68K 汇编编程，那是 CISC，即复杂指令集。我其实挺喜欢的。我不知道这是否被认为是深奥的。如果我这么说，可能会冒犯一些人。
But I feel like that was a pretty cool opportunity. So, you know, for a non-mainstream language for today, I think, you know, that would be my pick. That makes sense. All right. Let me just do a quick check of the other channels and the live show chat. I think we're good. All right, let me just do a quick check of the other channels and the live show chat. I think we're good. All right. Thank you, everybody, for a bunch of really interesting questions.
但我感觉那是一个非常酷的机会。所以，对于当今的非主流语言，我想，那会是我的选择。这很有道理。好了。让我快速检查一下其他频道和直播聊天室。我想我们没问题了。好了。让我快速检查一下其他频道和直播聊天室。我想我们没问题了。好了。非常感谢大家提出这么多有趣的问题。
It's been an amazing year. Thanks, Patrick, for taking so much time to be a huge part of the show. And we will catch you all next year. Patrick, any final words? Ah, thank you, Jason. And thank you for the compliments. Thank you for all the listeners out there as we beam this across.
这是很棒的一年。感谢 Patrick 花这么多时间成为节目中重要的一部分。我们明年再见。Patrick，有什么临别赠言吗？啊，谢谢 Jason。也谢谢你的赞美。感谢所有的听众，因为我们正在向外广播。
If you're an alien listening, send us your cobalt in an asteroid. All right. No, no, it's been great. It's another good year. And so, yeah, I i'm happy i'm thankful thankful for lots of things but uh thank you jason thank you for uh sticking with this and uh yeah all the work you do as well yeah totally all right everyone we'll catch you later have a good
如果你是外星听众，请把你们的钴矿通过小行星发给我们。好了。不，不，这很棒。又是美好的一年。所以，是的，我很开心，我很感激，感激很多事情，但谢谢你 Jason，谢谢你坚持做这个节目，还有你所做的所有工作。是的，完全同意。好了，各位，我们回头见，祝大家
year music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix, adapt the work. But you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
新年快乐。音乐由 Eric Barn Dollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，进行重混和改编。但你必须注明我和 Patrick 的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。